you know what to be honest with you a
little bit better we're alive okay guys
mike ritlin is going to pull out his new
book that just came out
that's selling your churches across the
country go ahead can you tell us the
title i believe it is called
mike's new book is called
unfuck america a respectful open-minded
conversation seems very respectful
dichotomy there yeah
so when did you write this book when did
this come out uh well so i wrote it
actually during the uh like when the
covet shutdowns kind of first took place
everything was was closed the kids were
home from school and so
i just used that as a as an opportunity
for me to work on that um
i was approached by uh by a publishing
house to uh to do a similar book but
you know immediately i thought my
thoughts on it coupled with you know
their their process of
uh you know editing and things like that
it's probably not going to make for uh
more than about a pamphlet's worth of
material when it's done so i just did it
myself and
and self-published so it's something
that i've been thinking about for a
while thank you is uh you know with a
lot of the conversations i've had on my
show with
experts of all different varieties
whether it's border drugs guns you know
child trafficking you name it is that i
wanted to have kind of a
an all-encompassing book that uh that
kind of shed light on
on all of those topics through the eyes
of of the show having had all these
experts on so
by the way we've had mike on mike you've
been on is it once or twice we haven't
joined twice right you've been on the
podcast
and one time you made comments about
women in navy seals
which uh
some loved some didn't like but a lot of
people wanted to find out more about it
and it was another comment uh video that
we did that was on what it was on uh
mike
i enrolled in mike's class on how to
understand guns and safety yeah and that
clip uh has pretty much gone viral half
a million views online and and
it's definitely opened my mind as to you
know he's carrying right now just so you
right now we finally got into kerry
yeah that's florida but at the same time
folks if you don't know mike ritlin yeah
he's a former navy seal dog trainer
millions of views and he's got a sense
of humor i'm telling you stick around
the guy's got a sense of humor he's got
a yogi barrel type of a sense of humor
that you have to have i think you have
to be
witty enough and sarcastic enough to
catch the sense of humor but it's there
it's for sure going to come out yeah
well hopefully it's not too low brown
mike hopefully it is
good
by the way i was um i was looking at the
clip that we did last time it performed
very well a lot of people really enjoyed
it thousands of comments
and then i happened to
uh
stumble across
images of you online naked
like he said he was performing well are
you on my only fans
that was happening i'm subscribed 9.99 a
month it's a fantastic look for you
loyalty tyler but look at this guy it's
either dogs or this guy looking chiseled
and it's uh that's uh implants in
photoshop i know what you're talking
about
but
i mean look at the top right picture
dude mike are you kidding me i'm not
kidding you it's not a joke is that you
it is but that's me on the left too as a
22 year old
baby frog man in hawaii now on the right
you can't your chest kind of looks
middle eastern it looks very hairy and
uh you spent some time there yeah i mean
that could happen
it rubs off for sure you know it is very
uh
contagious anyways guys we got a lot of
topics to get into
uh we're going to talk about the book as
well some things folks you got to know
about so news just came in isis leader
killed
in u.s special operations rate in syria
biden says uh he didn't do it himself
but it is something that uh uh just cam
i wanna make sure i put it out there
i've been flying off the helicopter
rambo style and just start unloading
here's the part that's the most
impressive one so this entire time
everybody's been trying to fix this
covet issue but president biden you got
to respect how aspirational he is
he has taken up a different challenge he
aims to reduce cancer death by 50 over
the next 25 years so he is attacking
cancer now they did such a good job with
kovitt now they're going after cancer
you tell me that's not impressive though
um hey kill cancer yeah that's that's
saying okay but but i'm i'm okay with
killing cancer what i'm not okay with
this let's first kill covet before
you're aspirational enough to kill
cancer you can't do two things at once
well now you can't do two things on but
kogan's over here was like no no don't
look here let's look over here let's
look over here gotcha maybe i'm wrong
right of hand kind of so brady made
comments about retirement there's one
thing he left out when he talked about
retirement he didn't think belichick he
didn't think brady he didn't think none
of them patriots fans nothing but i want
to read what belichick said which i
really like belgium's comments
uh and uh what he said uh zucker uh i
know you're heartbroken by this jeff
zucker from cnn yeah all night i didn't
get it you know i thought you were going
to cancel today i was a little bit
concerned i thought for sure i wasn't
here i would
i was going to cancel uh data came out
showing the fact that tucker carlson
nearly 40 percent of his viewers are
democrats
liberal leaders
that's a very interesting stuff whoopi
made some comments i definitely want to
get your commentary on that on what you
think about what she said
saki uh actually responded about joe
rogan being censored and did you guys
hear about how many coveted related
uh videos and podcasts as spotify took
down in the last few weeks did you guys
see the buttons i heard
that 20
000. what 20 000 clips 20 000 anything
related to cover that could be
misinformed clips anything that was not
episode no podcast podcast episode long
form what twenty
thousand were taking this spotify made
that decision so recently yes so so
they're saying now that spotify is maybe
caving in and it's kind of you know
going a different direction boy daniel
elk
daniel eck i know you're feeling like
going to casa to have some elk but it's
daniel ecky so 20 000 of them aoc
heartbreaking she's dealing with anxiety
because of her visiting florida and she
got a lot of criticism for visiting
florida so she's not wanting to get on
twitter because she gets too much
criticism and we have to kind of lower
the criticism there so folks just
disclaimer to everybody next time if you
see her video please take it easy on her
um and then we got a few other things
vox did a story you ready for this vox
story when i saw this title i almost
thought it was a joke
it said remote work isn't the problem
you know what's the problem work is the
problem what
so let's not have to let's not work
anymore uh and uh let's get everybody to
stay home and then you know we broke a
record u.s is officially in debt 30
trillion dollars okay it's
congratulations yeah yeah it's in
america it's so bad that babylon b wrote
an article about it satire article about
it saying the debt is so high that
immigrants are turning back around and
going back home
anyways okay so let's go into this so
isis this news just came up if you want
to pull this up with the isis story and
let's kind of go through this if you can
uh make it a little bit bigger so the
viewers can see it uh so here we go by
u.s raid in syria killed top isis
leader go a little lower so we can read
it in a mic if you can give us some
thoughts on this
president biden said on thursday that
the u.s raid in western syria killed top
isis leader abu ibrahim al-hashimi el
qurashi
what he's saying is last night at my
direction u.s military forces at my
direction very impressive u.s military
forces in northwest syria successfully
undertook a counter-terrorism operation
to protect the american people and our
allies and make the world a safer place
biden said thanks to the skill and
bravery of our armed forces we have
taken off battlefield abu ibrahim the
leader of isis all americans have
returned safely from the operations
monitoring and other groups
as well as residents of the raided
village atem atme in the rebel-held
idlib province near the border with
turkey reported multiple deaths
including civilians british
internationals nine people uh were
killed in thursday's strike including
two children and a woman wow okay so
that's the part that's gonna british
monetary
group the syrian observatory for human
rights said at least nine people were
killed on thursday's strike including
two children and a woman the syrian
civil events first response responders
also known as the white helmet said at
least 13 people died including six
children in shelling and clashes that
followed the raid so mike former navy
seal when you see something like this
what are you thinking and what do you
know about it
well in terms of detail that i know
about it is uh basically zero uh with it
being this new and me having been out as
long as i have i i have no no
connections as to any you know pertinent
details but what i will say is that
you know stuff like this takes place
pretty regularly um
from a from a timing standpoint you know
it's easy to look at it and say
it's a shell game of hey things are
going bad so let me do something like
this you know there's a potential for
that no no two ways about it but i think
it's always good when when things like
this happen uh as it relates to
keeping
terrorist groups accountable overseas
and
uh you know keeping the pressure on them
there so that you know they they feel
the heat there and it's harder for them
to execute things uh you know over here
but i just don't uh i i don't like the
timing of it i guess you know it does
seem a little a little convenient
because
we haven't done anything uh over there
you know his debacle or botched
abortion of a of a withdrawal from
afghanistan um
you know to me still stings and always
will for for most
guys who have had any involvement in the
war on terror in the last 20 years and
so
it's hard for me not to have some bias
coming into a story like this just
because of how how badly he's fumbled uh
military
policy in in the short year that he's
been at the helm if you can even call it
that by the way tyler can you go uh copy
paste his name and go on google copy
paste his name abu yeah i've never even
heard of her yeah
go on google and let's read the
wikipedia because i've been going
through the wikipedia uh golden lore
yeah go little lord the main wikipedia
it's a little concerning because it's
born in october go a little lower there
you go okay good all right make it
bigger
i want someone to go let's see the born
of german or
october 1976 february 3rd 2022 was an
iraqi islamist and the second leader
okay so he was second in command of the
islamic state
his appointment by a shura council was
announced by the islamic state media
31st of october 2019 less than a week
after the death of previous leader abu
bakr okay so he got appointed after the
u.s rewards the justice program was
offering 10 million dollars in exchange
for information leading to
uh his apprehension so does biden get
the 10 million on february 3rd 2022
he killed themselves
by triggering an explosive device during
the counter-terrorism rate by u.s joint
special operations wait so he killed
himself so he did the same thing that
baghdadi did as he blew himself up when
they were coming to get him
remember that they sent the dogs after
back yeah into the cave and he blew
himself yeah he's not going to give you
the pride of killing him he's going to
do it himself and his family which is
nice okay so so explain that by the way
you'd rather be you'd rather kill
yourself set off an explosive kill
yourself and your family yeah rather
than being taken out by infidels i would
explain that but uh i wish i could go
from their mentality you spend time over
there how does that work well i mean to
me it doesn't again you know trying to
understand the the mindset and the
mentality of these guys even though you
know know your enemy and you want to
understand who you're fighting
uh is very very difficult for that
reason is that there's such a disparity
culturally between here and there and
religious uh you know values and things
of that nature that it makes it
uh i'll say for me even not being a
religion a religious guy uh really
really difficult to understand what the
mentality is there i mean i can't
understand him doing what he does to
begin with let alone
killing himself but it's
it's such a backwards mentality as far
as the
the way that you know hardline extremist
guys in in these networks and such the
way that they they and their families
view
uh suicide bombers is
of a very high regard right well
apparently you know according to the
quran if you blow yourself up
you know in the the name of allah you
literally go to heaven you get 72
virgins
that's part of their mantra yeah i mean
i don't know uh i don't know that it
that it speaks to actual suicide in the
quran but i know that uh you know from
from the twisted
versions of
a lot of the the networks over there
uh and we'll even say uh afghanistan i
had uh holly mckay on my show uh just a
couple weeks ago who was there during
the the withdrawal
um you know in the the viewpoint and
stance that that a lot of that culture
uh you know kind of looks at
as far as the the suicide bomber
mentality is that those uh let's say
there's a 17 year old son and uh you
know he blows himself up at a checkpoint
and what have you is that that family is
now almost considered royalty like
they're paid they're they're revered
they're they're held at a really high
standard societally because their son
blew himself yeah now the family is
revered right and so other
families see that and and they encourage
their their kids to do it and their kids
these are their kids
these are our sports figures our actors
yeah i mean they're like
that's why would be suicide bomber
baseball cards here before too long i'll
tell you one thing i actually um
had an uber ride from fort lauderdale to
miami
to miami and in miami there's a 90
chance that your uber driver is going to
be of latino descent whether that's
cuban or colombian or venezuelan i mean
just that's my the makeup of the dna in
south florida this particular man was
actually palestinian
and uh we got into a whole long
conversation he's like so where you from
miami you're jewish yeah yeah i love
jews i'm like oh you're palestinian yes
yes you know like he got he's been in
america
for 30 plus years so thick accent and we
had a very unique conversation you know
a jew a
palestinian driver and we we actually
exchanged numbers and he
was actually on new year's he actually
picked us up later with the point is we
had a great time and he said something
he goes you got you have to understand
one thing about these types of people
he goes i'm a muslim but i'm very
moderate he goes
they value death
more than we value life yeah and i said
whoa what
and he goes yeah they value death more
than we value life and and we just
discussed that what that meant
and i mean that kind of to your point
here mike is that
their mentality their values are totally
different than
any normal person would would have yeah
yeah absolutely there's that's half of
it too is the other half is that you
know the the economies and societies
over there overwhelmingly so have a kind
of a feeling of despair almost you know
like that there's unemployment rates
must be just amazing
the lack of infrastructure
just there's so many negatives in in the
societies there that there's not a lot
to want to live for frankly you know and
so when you couple that with
an isolated extremist uh conditioning
from a religious standpoint and talking
about the afterlife and
you know basically brainwashing people
no different than than some aspects of
society here frankly but
but there it's it's just supercharged to
a level where it's kind of a perfect
storm of all these different elements
that contribute to
it making it very easy for them to
manipulate young
piss broke families into into sending
their their kids into
into those scenarios but let me ask you
this rasmus
when we when he was killed
did he get a lot of negative
pushback from the opposing side on why
would you take somebody out that
powerful like i remember one this is the
iranian this is like the head of the cia
fbi
yeah and zeller said i don't know if
that was the right move to make right to
do something like they're still talking
about they're still talking about it
till today oh yeah and they're not gonna
forget about this guy because this guy
had a very
uh uh up big upside he could have been
the face of the country as a leader to
to to keep
pushing their agenda their philosophies
right
what happens with a situation like this
what what's the next
uh uh a could there be a possibility of
a revenge or pushback or the side
effects of doing something like this or
is it more positive for isis to know
listen
if you do anything we're going to
constantly come
and keep doing this to you so yeah
is it a positive move on what happened
is there any negative thing that could
happen here to me that's 100 positive
you know
is there going to be or is there a
potential for blowback revenge of course
there is but that to me you should never
base decisions as to whether or not you
do something based on
on how somebody might uh retaliate based
on that if it's the right you have to
anticipate it though right you should be
anticipating that something could happen
yeah but i i mean i look at it as as
kind of a a net
reaction as far as uh you know if
there's 5 000 capable guys with a you
know combat experience with
strategic value with uh you know
logistical expertise that are within
these organizations it's always better
to remove as many of those people as
possible uh you know irrespective of
what potential blowback might be i mean
no different than say your company here
like if somebody wanted to take out your
company you know does the thought of you
hiring you know the next best guy or
bringing somebody else in or replacing
whoever is that going to deter them from
trying to to crumble your company no
like they're just going to come at you
harder you know even if you they know
you're going to respond in kind or or
what have you no different than them
you've had a bunch of mob bosses on
similar mentality there is that they're
going to take out who who needs to be
taken out and who's going to be value
value added to being lost by that
organization so yeah i got to tell you i
like this i like that this happened
because
for a minute we seemed sloppy yeah for a
minute we seemed weak for a minute it
was like you know these guys can't
handle anything i love the fact that
something like this happened forget
who's in the white house it's great that
america is seen with something like this
taking place now it's tragic when you
read it and saying because look how this
one wrote it this one wrote it let's
stay right there on the article it says
the syrian civil defense first
responders alhams at least 13 people
died including six children and shelling
in clashes that followed the raid right
yeah so you read that and it doesn't
look positive it looks negative
british monitoring group the syrian
observatory for human rights that at
least nine people were killed and
thursday's strike but we don't two
children and a woman but you don't know
if he'd kill those kids we don't know
who those two are those those his kids
because on wikipedia says he killed
himself right he blew himself up i'd be
here soon as information comes in to see
uh what that situation was like
uh in syria mike um
years ago i mean a handful of years ago
we all we would hear about was the
syrian civil war i remember when gary
johnson the libertarian party was
running for president this was in 2016
when when trump won and and obviously
edged out hillary clinton he completely
[ __ ] the bed because they said what are
your thoughts on what's going on with
aleppo
right and he's like what's up he's like
what's a lappo i was like brady you want
to be president you don't know the
capital of syria what the hell are you
talking about right now and that guy was
done um but what is going on in syria
these days we heard so much about assad
chemical warfare on their citizens uh
you know isis you know it's so like
you have you have isis and then you have
the taliban in afghanistan and then you
have syria and the dictators and like
the shiites and the sunnis and these
people and then the kurds up there it's
we can't figure out who to kill who and
then syrian the government is fighting
isis but we're fighting isis but we're
also against assad
we don't hear a lot about it this is the
pat's point what just can you make some
sense of it or is there no way to make
sense of what to do going over there
well being a part-time janitor at the
cia let me tell you what's going on
uh
i mean the short answer is is it's not
as involved as it was you know four
years ago is it still a mess the same
way a lot of places uh
are still a mess over there yes
you know to try to to dissect it and
understand uh you know the cause and
effect and and what is really going on i
mean to me you really need to spend time
there
um you know and and
try to evaluate it from a almost from a
journalist standpoint of of not taking
sides and just there figuring out what
what that is
why there's not more attention paid to
it i think just really stems from the
fact that afghanistan uh you know heated
up with with the draw down and then the
the debacle of the
of the withdrawal from there as well as
you know iran getting nuclear material
and and you know things happening
between
israel and
in palestine the same way that it has
you know for the last several years and
so it's
there's just so many different things
going on there that are all kind of
equally terrible
um you know i wouldn't say that it's
necessarily any worse than than
seven other places over there it's just
you're not hearing about it because
there's there's no reason to hear about
it there's not an election going on we
have almost no involvement over there
and so it's just not on the radar
especially with you know something like
covid
uh here
making such a big deal out of that it's
just uh it's a priority thing and is
isis still as powerful or though they're
not anywhere no they're nowhere near as
powerful do they still exist yes i mean
there's a faction there's isis k in
afghanistan that's caused a lot of
problems but
um you know to me they're they're
smaller than they used to be
quite a bit uh mostly the four years
that trump was in office of really
getting getting after it from an
offensive standpoint as opposed to to a
reactive standpoint in what way
just i mean
operations like this
times a thousand you know there was a
lot more troop presence there uh you
know we we took a lot of
intelligence based uh measures to to
execute missions like this and and other
ones to to push them back and take
territory back and and get rid of high
value targets and things of that nature
so mike how much is this when an
operation like this is taking place the
white house is aware of it a month two
months three months six months a year
prior to it happening like is this
something that biden knew about three
six months ago or could is it last
minute hey guys here's where we are we
found them let's make the phone call
take them out boom yeah so generally
speaking you know there's kind of a
pulse or tabs on guys in certain areas
when something like this happens it's
generally
to a degree with which there's very very
credible and corroborated through
multiple sources viable intelligence
that this guy is right here and now we
can go find him which is why you know
this is a big deal is that to to
pinpoint a guy and actually be accurate
as to his exact location going and
finding him even though we didn't kill
him he blew himself up the fact is the
result is the same is that that's a big
deal intelligence uh
wise you know as far as a victory so we
knew about it for for sure now
he's been on the radar is what you're
saying yeah yeah but the opportunity uh
arises
but but what what's not said and what's
very possible i don't have any intimate
knowledge of it how many times did we
think he was somewhere tried to go and
nothing happened who knows it could have
been a dozen
you know so um
that's the the tricky part with this
like to your question
you know the the different directors in
you know people in different places of
of
of a high value uh in our government
that know okay this guy's in this region
this guy's in that region this outfit's
operating here they have about this many
troops
you know you have a good idea
i'm gonna ask a crazy question and i
just want you to be thinking about it
both of you guys say tyler you think
about a c c see how you process this so
you know sometimes somebody all of a
sudden has a bad rep for something they
did and they hire a publicist and the
publicist comes and tries to rebrand the
person right like a rod rebranded
himself very well until the jlo
situation it kind of went back to
what it was i think a little bit right
he took a little bit of a step back but
when a-rod came back out a-rod was
this guy listen i did it
here's what i did this is what it is
he's definitely transforming and then he
was on you know shark tank you're seeing
him everywhere so you're like dude this
guy's incredible on tv great
communicator great all this stuff then
some people were up so what happened
with jlo no one knows a real story what
happened there the jlo fans came out and
didn't like him but a-rod recreated his
persona would you guys both agree who
else would you put in that category that
recreated their persona at that level i
think
musicians do it rappers do it kardashian
did it
stars do it all the time right and
especially when you're getting older you
got to do it even more because if you
don't you're no longer 22 you're now 53
you don't look like you did at 22. you
got to kind of mix it up right i wonder
if there's meetings where you're sitting
there saying look let's face it man and
by the way this i'm talking any
president look your you know score right
now your polls you're really good your
rating sucks right now you ain't looking
good it's talking about nothing i'm not
buying them midterms are coming up we
got to kind of fix some things up so
listen five step plan here's what we're
going to do no longer we're going to
talk about covert we're going to talk
about cancer number two we need a strong
position from urine to go take out
somebody from isis let's call this
number three we need to do do you think
those types of conversations happen they
have to okay i agree i mean
no doubt
and i wonder if there's like a
30 point marker of things to do to
recreate your reputation
in these 30 markers okay which one of
these do we want to do let's take this
this this this this you've had a
publicist before right sure know your
relationship
yeah it's their job to make you look
better to recreate you give you better
talking points all right listen you're
going to get off the cover thing you're
gonna start focusing on cancer buddy you
just
botched afghanistan let's kill some
mofos in syria this is
i think this is
you know pr 101 like get your ratings
back up and i think i needed that and
and to your point pat i think it's
important and i want to get mike's
thoughts on this as well notice it was a
raid and they didn't send in a drone
they didn't send in a reaper because
what happened last time we did that we
killed the aid worker and what seven
children yeah drone pat tillman i mean
so so where does that come from the is
it situational where they decide to raid
or yeah it is i mean so much of it is
going to be driven by kind of the the
actionable intelligence on what's on
target now
speaking from personal experience you
know we we did operations where our
intelligence was spot on and there were
times where we did uh operations where
the intelligence was woefully inaccurate
um you know and that's kind of the the
dice role that you take with any of
these things is that it's always
from a collateral damage standpoint i
would say generally speaking not always
it's it's a better mechanism to to send
human beings there to execute a mission
because they're they're thinking on
target now it doesn't mean that it can't
go wrong where
civilians are using
or being used as shields or kids get
blown up or things of that nature but
you at least have a
an interactive component on the ground
that can make decisions
whereas you know once once the trigger
is pulled on a on a drone hellfire uh
you know that that's it so
um
you know when it comes to to things like
this it's
it's generally uh regarded as the better
decision for the big picture to send
people now the obvious drawback is that
what if some of our our guys get lost
my my perception
of especially how this administration
would would view that is that uh that
that's not a huge consideration on their
part it's a hundred percent how is it
going to make us look good or
uh you know what what is the pr going to
be based on on something like this
happening mike
sorry
the human capital yeah um
is a two-part question um
well first let me give a retraction i
believe i called uh
aleppo the uh capital of uh of syria
it's damascus but it's a major city and
either way i don't want to get you know
slammed in the country under the
comments this guy doesn't mean don't
read them
believe me i don't my question to you is
that regarding our allies
we know who our enemies are the isis k
the isis you know the taliban the list
goes on and on and on who are our
biggest
allies
in the middle east
right and where they house like these
where did these where were these guys
based out of obviously we know israel
who else is on our list of allies we
know the enemies who are the allies so
so to me it's it's kind of a tough
question because it depends on on what
position you take and who you are even
within our government
having said that jordan historically has
been what i would consider probably our
biggest ally in the region outside of
israel
um i i don't think saudi for a number of
reasons which would be its own episode
by itself uh you know doesn't have any
of our best interests in mind 911 being
a clear-cut example
and and all the rest of the countries
it's it's not that black and white as
far as just like with with our country
right is that you've got even within our
government you've got people on polar
opposite spectrums of so there's no
countries other than israel or jordan
you would put on that list what about
regions or types like the kurds we
always hear about the kurds they're
great fighters and they were fighting
against yeah the northern third of iraq
is is generally a a considerable ally
for us um but we've turned our back on
them a few times and and totally sold
them out so
you know to to say that there are a
staunch ally and we can depend on them i
wouldn't say i remember trump caught a
lot of heat about pulling out and
basically
people don't recall as much heat as
biden took in afghanistan for the sloppy
withdrawal there was a brief period of
time where trump was taking a lot of
heat from abandoning the kurds not as
big as afghanistan because though people
don't know that but do you recall that
not really um you know and maybe that's
uh maybe that's the media portion i
don't know you know to me the the the
abandonment of them happened well before
he got in office i mean it happened four
years prior to that it happened in my
opinion midway through obama's term so
to me to depend pin that on
on trump i think is uh is disingenuous
because it's
the the rise of of isis took place
halfway through obama's term with
without question so when he called them
the jv uh yeah and he just you know he
pulled basically all of the the
territory that we had territory uh you
know
all of the regions and areas in iraq
that we
had fought so hard to secure just like
we did in afghanistan and basically just
pulled everybody back
uh withdrew almost every troop from from
the region and just let
isis steamroll through there and and uh
just i mean the things that they did
there was
i mean hard to even wrap your mind
around and that took place for years
before trump came out the united states
always always always need to have a
presence in the middle east i don't
think so no really i don't think so no i
mean i i take much more of a
i would say bordering on isolationist
viewpoint uh in terms of foreign policy
at this point i mean to me i reduce or i
i tend to reduce foreign policy all the
way down to such a micro level like a
bar fight right and to me they're
they're interchangeable that way is that
you're walking uh by your favorite club
right and there's a huge fight going on
now you can walk in there and you can
help the guy that has four dudes pinning
him down and bashing his head in or you
can help the woman that's getting
slapped around you know whatever it is
just by walking in there you're gonna
piss somebody off
no matter who you help you're gonna piss
somebody off and you're gonna create
enemies right and so to me i think world
war ii is the most clear-cut example on
how to handle things at a at a
geopolitical or international level
where you don't get involved until you
have to but when you do you take the
[ __ ] gloves off and you go over there
until the job is done and you do
whatever is necessary to come to
sherman's style from the civil war but
isn't that what we did
after 9 11
we were kind of out for about two months
we were out of afghanistan we had no
involvement
and then we went no qatar bahrain saudi
i mean
exercises in jordan
joint operations in israel we've been
heavily footprinted in the middle east
way more than we need to be for decades
i mean it started back in honestly when
when the first persian gulf war took
place and and you know we got bombed in
in saudi arabia for being there i mean
that that's really when when it really
started in my opinion where
uh the hardline group specifically al
qaeda i mean that that was born out of
saudi allowing us to have troops in in
the region uh to defend kuwait that
pissed osama bin laden off to the point
where
he created al-qaeda because of that so
um you know to me there there's been a
lot of involvement that we've had that's
that's unnecessarily created problems
that uh
you know that that we're we're still
paying for and these people fear the
united states military for sure they do
they do 100 and even just as recent as
seven months ago that the fact that we
had 2500 troops in afghanistan and they
still weren't doing anything until biden
was like yeah we're actually leaving and
they closed down the air base
the fact that that just 2500 troops held
the the taliban at bay because you saw
how fast they took the country over
right it was supposed to be months and
then right literally was days it wasn't
2500 troops it was the fact that we
still had a presence there and they knew
if they tried to do that while we still
were taking the stance of we are here
that it would have been 2.0 afghanistan
we would have come back in and they
would have paid for it i mean you can
see it in their operations with
um
attacking certain bases and
knowing when you know how long they have
before you know close air support is
going to be there i mean there's a
healthy respect for it or they would
have done what they did seven months ago
18 years ago
there's a reason they didn't do it that
entire time
how how worried should we be that we
left behind what was it 80 billion
dollars of military equipment i mean at
this point to be worried about it i
think is fruitless but uh is it is it a
kick in the gut yes absolutely uh do i
think that they're gonna take those
assets and and now
you know
launch attacks in into america no i
don't i think it sucks is it going to
turn them into
an overnight success no it isn't i mean
if you look at how much money we put
into
forces in iraq and afghanistan and doing
you know foreign internal defense with a
lot of other countries over there
you know we we've spent at this point
trillions of dollars on equipment and
training i mean i i've worked with guys
before
to have the capabilities that the united
states has takes a whole another level
of
uh generational dedication that just
isn't there you know so am i worried
about it ultimately no does it piss me
off yes it does by the way while this
whole thing's going on the story comes
out from the washington free beacon
about iran being weeks away from having
full
fuel to power atomic bomb uh state
department warns iran will have enough
uh
fissile material enriched to weapon
great capacity in weeks not months a
senator a senior state department
official said monday following the
conclusion of another round of indirect
talks with iran and world powers in
vienna following 10 months of
negotiations the state department
department says diplomacy
uh diplomacy will cease in the coming
weeks whether iran takes a deal or not
this is because the biden administration
assesses that iran's nuclear program
will have become so advanced that
re-entering the 2015 nuclear accord will
provide no benefits to u.s and global
national security in the re years
since trump withdrew from the deal iran
has enriched uranium the key component
and a bomb so extremely high levels of
purity negotiations are paused as
iranian diplomats travel back to tehran
to consult with the hardline ruling
government if iran takes the deal
virtually all u.s sanctions imposed by
trump administration will evaporate
giving the regime access to billions of
dollars of cash
is that a concern to you with what's
going on there with iran i mean it is
but i also think you know this is kind
of to adam's question of of involvement
is that you you really have to decide
do we want them or are we okay with them
having this or are we not
if the answer is is we're not and we
need to stop it then as a country you
have to decide we will do what is
necessary to prevent that whatever that
is right is that if it's if it's that
red line like hey iran cannot have the
capability to have any nuclear capacity
whatsoever
if that means that that we carpet bomb
you know the the facilities we you know
what whatever it takes
intelligence-based uh
you know wise is that that's what you do
you know no again no different than
afghanistan iraq world war ii whatever
is is that you know to me the cat and
mouse aspect of of the negotiations and
in the accords and the peace deals and
the cash and all these other things are
kind of a distraction
in that you just have to ask yourself
are we going to be
are we going to sit on the sideline
while they do it or not now whether or
not we we take action that that's a
whole other conversation but i think
as a country there needs to be a
decision one way or another and you just
do whatever here's my question how do we
know how do we even know that this is
taking place right now like how why is
how do we know that iran is
weeks away from having fuel to fuel
power atomic bomb how do we know that
what insider information is yvonne iran
leaking to us they're not going to leak
anything to the states i mean so this is
where you know that i'll be careful in
how i tread on on what i say but uh
there there are intelligence assets that
that provide the capabilities through a
a number of resources and that's
electronic human
uh you know traditional spying uh you
know communications intelligence etc uh
all kind of coupled together to make
determinations and assessments like that
uh but that's really awesome how how
deep are we as
and i'm gonna go a little bit deeper you
you to hear what you're gonna say about
this
how deep is
u.s whether you want to put cia or you
know whatever you want to call it in
iran
to
constantly gather intel and send it to
us are we pretty involved heavily there
or it's mild i i would say uh
again not not having
maybe as intimate not as knowledge as
maybe you would assume
but what i do know is is just again from
having you know a lot of friends that do
do things like that and and having
worked in that capacity is that there
are always people involved in in all of
the kind of big actors and that's in
every one of those capacities that i
just mentioned it's signal intelligence
it's
communications it's human it's all of
those things and so
you know the the united states has has
this map of okay here are all the the
major concerns and then they dedicate
assets based on the same way say an er
doctor would triage an emergency room
after an accident is that this is the
biggest threat this you know and they're
they're allocating resources based on
that so without a doubt there is is
moderate um you know to to heavy
involvement in uh every capacity that we
have the ability to be involved in in
that country specifically and also don't
forget i mean our our position keeps
changing whether it was the uh biden who
led the charge on the iran nuclear deal
uh trump pulled out you know now biden
is getting back in it whatever it is but
there's one thing that has not wavered
and that's israel yeah
our stance says change here in the
united states israel is
dead set on iran not being a nuclear
power so whether that's them taking out
scientists taking out plants like they
are not playing around they do not want
iran to have this nuclear power yeah i
mean it's a much bigger threat to them
than it is to us
yeah i mean yeah they're right there
obviously the iranian rhetoric is we're
going to wipe them off the map they
don't want israel to exist yeah i mean
no different than if uh you know say
china built a
an air force base in in tijuana right
like we're going to be a lot more
bent about that than israel is because
it's right there you know
cuba
russia has a
um you know an an amphibious assault
group or an aircraft carrier
uh you know 30 miles off the coast of
california you know is israel gonna
say yeah that's messed up and that we
don't think they should do that or
whatever probably are they gonna be as
worried about it as we are absolutely
not you know geographically the united
states has to just be
i mean we're very lucky that we're not
in the middle of all this nonsense in
the middle east eurasia anything like
that yeah i mean geographically it
certainly uh
is at our advantage i will say the more
technologically advanced the human race
becomes the less that matters
uh whether it's cyber attacks or
satellite stuff [ __ ] coming you know
lasers from outer space type stuff
the the more and more capable
human beings become from from a
technology standpoint it's not going to
matter as much it already doesn't i mean
china has the ability to do what they do
as well as russia i mean they've they've
made our lives uh pretty difficult over
the last decade both of them uh from
without ever even having to come here
you know so
it still plays a role i'd still
i'd still rather have a geographical
advantage than not
um you know but that that gap is
shortening year after year
you know you you wonder when you think
about this stuff like even with iran
because iran signed a 25 year 400
billion dollar deal with
china right that's the deal that they
signed when they
said hey you want to do this trump we're
going to go take advantage this and get
with china and china is the number one
competitor to
us
do you think today's administration of
iran cares whether they have a good
relationship with us or not like do you
think they wake up in the morning saying
okay let's have a meeting guys let's
figure out a way how we can be better
with u.s do you think they give a [ __ ]
at all i would say it's probably the
opposite is that they're they're trying
to come up with ways to piss us off get
under our skin and and degrade that
relationship i totally agree okay so if
that's the case
and they're saying well we're going back
to see
10 months of negotiation state
department says the diplomacy will cease
with coming weeks after they're going to
go back to tehran you think they care
like do you think they're sitting there
saying hey boss we have to improve this
relationship with us or else are we
going to lose
yeah personal questions yeah go for it
being born in iran yeah and being a
proud iranian born in iran made in
america serving in the military being a
world-class entrepreneur
when you hear these types of stories or
just iran comes up how does that make
you feel just as a as a
citizen yeah all i think about is
progress all i think about is i got kids
that i'd like to show them
jet that i was raised on a street called
hojet i want to take him to bandar
pahlavi port of pallavi to show him
caspian sea i want to take him to jam
hospital where i was born
i want to take him to the kebab place we
would go to hooch i want to take him to
the city gandhi you know i want to take
him i want to go show them those places
i can't i want to take them to espahan
which is the only place we went on
vacation with my mom and dad when they
were married to each other i i listened
to the song by mauin
who's a famous persian singer who sings
a song saying de la mix
my heart wants me to return back to
esperan it's the only vacation i ever
went to it's a great song it's a very uh
heartfelt song i i i love that song so i
i think about progress for me to go i
want to go visit iran tomorrow i want to
go see what that place is at tomorrow
i i remember going to the shaw's
castles and mansions and visiting it and
touring and seeing all these pictures
being
upside down that's what i think about so
for me every time i hear stories like
this
i think to myself we're going backwards
because remember the green part was it
the green party in iran that was trying
to do a coup do you remember the green
party uh can you pull up iran green
party it was something like that the
green movement or green party they had
something that was going on
iran uh a
green party of iran yeah they were they
were pushing back to
get iran to be free again you saw them
at the embassy you were seeing them
everywhere and they were making some
progress under trump there was a minute
where the people of iran could have
revolted to change things but every time
it happens
a president changes
i think if trump would have stayed
president for eight years and he would
have just kept going if you remember gas
prices at one point were so expensive
people just stood there they're not even
driving duck i can't afford to buy gas i
don't know iran you don't remember this
like a year and a half ago it was so bad
people just
are walking they're like i can't how am
i going to pay for this gas price the
sanctions were out of control it was
that time but the point is
as much as you're saying well the
sanctions were out of control if the
current regime in iran falls
somebody has to replace it and that
somebody that replaces is hoping to be a
different philosophy with relationships
with
neighboring countries like israel would
be better u.s would be better and it
would be back and forth but it's not
been like that since 1978. yeah i want
to go to iran tomorrow but i can't go to
iran tomorrow so if my motives are a
different motive then maybe the average
person's motive that's worried about the
fact that we keep got some selling money
and hey these guys going to retaliate
and do another 911 to u.s i'm coming
from a different state where does
because you're a christian
and i don't know what percentage of iran
are christians i i'm sure one percent is
less than jewish less than one percent
but they're the stronghold of hold of
shiites in the middle east and the rest
of the middle east is for the most part
sunni how does that weigh into their
relationships with the rest of the
middle east uh being a being the shiite
stronghold of them it's not going to be
pretty it's not going to be easy because
some people don't want the revolution to
happen some people want it to stay the
way it is
and the reality of it is in order for
revolution to happen
it's going to cost a lot of people's
lives it's not going to be pretty it's
going to be very ugly for that to be
taking place and you know as a parent
think about your mom your dad and you
got kids okay
and you're sitting there and you want a
revolution to happen you want iran to go
let's just say you're 70 years old you
remember when iran was amazing you're 50
years old you remember when iran was
great you wanted to go back to that but
at the same time to go back to that
you encourage your kids too much
to be radical and take a stand do you
really want to have some bad news of
somebody you know giving you a call
saying hey here's what happened to your
kid
your fear is what they're going to do to
your kids so you
almost discourage your kids of wanting
to revolt remember
this guy who got
erated
from isis was willing to take a life of
his wife and his kids
and himself to not give you the victory
that is so radical if you think about
that i mean to to to be willing to do
something like that
i don't think the reasonable people on
the opposing side
are willing to risk their kids having to
go out there protesting and god forbid
somebody gets killed they're like listen
guys it's not worth it let's just let's
just be okay it's not a big deal so
they're not pushing back what would a
revolution even look like in iran
because correct me if i'm wrong i don't
think that people have access to guns
that sound like a second amendment the
only way it happens is with help you're
not gonna do it without help there has
to be another country that's helping
it's not gonna happen just by the people
what providing ammunition guns military
support
involvement yeah it's heavily the
heavy-duty involvement it's not you the
people won't be able to do it are there
uh do you have relatives that are still
there that you keep in contact with uh i
do yes from my mother's side we have
relatives there is it uh difficult or
like does that come up at all where you
talk about kind of the the pulse of
what's going on there and we we don't
really talk about any of that stuff i
suppose they can't probably right i mean
it's being monitored no you don't want
to put them at risk if you even if you
even think about having those types of
conversations now but here's what's
interesting like today i'm talking about
this right i'm probably going to get 50
messages on instagram or twitter or
some social media platform of iranians
that are listening to our podcast
through a vpn underground system and
they're sending messages hey keep
talking about the stuff because we're
listening hey keep talking about the
stuff because we're listening but you
know in order for that to happen you
need an administration that doesn't look
at them and say hey you know this is
let's just negotiate with them
it's very hard to negotiate with
reasonable people it's very very
unreasonable very hard when you're
negotiating with unreasonable people no
progress is going to take place these
guys are not reasonable people well this
is where you need to add them into
mike's point this is where you need
israel to step up and the peace accords
that have come through the middle east
that israel is making because
everybody's biggest fear right now is
iran that's where you need these people
to step up so we don't have to you know
what israel has done plenty of stuff i
mean israel will go take out scientists
israel is not afraid israel is the kind
of place that they'll they'll play the
proxy but they're not afraid to play the
direct without a proxy i don't know if
that makes sense like they're not trying
to use somebody they're still relying on
us to to take charge they are but
they'll still come at you as one as well
and say i did it they'll do it alone
yeah if we don't like especially with
this i wouldn't be surprised if you see
a legit
like you said this is us and we're not
not trying to hide it you know attack on
uh on different whether it's nuke sites
or or scientific scientist locations or
what have you
it'll be interesting to see what happens
all i know is i'd love to see iran
open up so we can go
tour and show the entire place and see
how beautiful the country iran is so you
go to a lot of museums there's a hundred
year old building 200 year old building
you go to like 3 000 euro building yeah
studio i am curious like from from kind
of a an investment standpoint here like
do you think it's worth the united
states getting involved at that level
not not right now because it's 25 years
400 billion dollars with china
is it worth paying more than 400 billion
dollars no
iran's the day iran signed that 25 year
400 billion dollars we probably lost
iran for a few decades i guess i mean an
investment from a a blood and treasure
standpoint uh like the the sacrifice
that it would take for the united states
to actually get involved and and
overthrow the the regime it's not worth
it because the only way to be worth it
is in a following way
so here here's the only strategy again
i'm i'm not involved in any kind this is
just i'm thinking like a strategist is
you need
a a couple things in place you need a
trump-like personality
that is hurting china first
okay hurting china first china has to
feel the pain
then
u.s has to say
if you don't pull out of this deal with
iran
we're going to increase the tariffs to
40 percent
so then china says china the
announcement comes out saying china
pulled out of the iran deal for 25 your
phone a billion dollars
that's progress do you remember when
huawei do you remember the company in
huawei do you remember when every day
everything we talked about was huawei
huawei huawei 5g huawei what do you
remember that whole story communication
telecommunication and then one day what
does trump do with huawei
bans the phone
remember why we did we were one of the
bigger markets they were growing here
they were exploding and then do you
remember the situation where the huawei
cfo who happens to be the daughter of
the owner who in canada got caught you
remember that story in canada she got
caught and then she had dealings doing a
deal
with iran huawei was do you remember
this whole story or no vaguely type in
huawei cfo canada iran huawei cfo canada
iran and tap in iran as well
dealing okay mengzu can return to china
admits helping huawei conceal dealings
in iran there you go this was a story
washington po wapo what date was this
national security go up a little bit
uh do you see the date september 24th
yeah this is not that long ago this is
five months ago this is six months ago
but this has been going on for a while
so
so the only way it would work
is if trump says
here's more uh tariffs here's more
terrorists here's more tariffs and in
china says screw this guy you know what
iran were pulling out then they pull out
then his next move would be tariffs to
iran then him saying no other middle
eastern banks can do business with iran
all the banks tighten up the people get
pissed off with the regime of course
they're going to blame u.s ford and then
at that time was like do we want this
regime to be here then they revolt it's
like a five-step process of getting
there but it won't happen without china
yeah
it won't happen without china so
we get them uh then we can do something
with iran other than china what other
country from a business standpoint
dealing standpoint are invested in iran
or or is iran doing business with
actively let me ask you a question who
do you think is more that's a pretty
weird question to ask who's more
reasonable putin or g
who's more reasonable i have an answer
it's not even close gut is telling me
putin it's not even close
i'm telling you it's not even close
that you think putin is more reasonable
there is no way it's even close
that putin is more reasonable than she
is
there's no way you're saying she is the
least reasonable person let me ask you a
question are you more worried about
visiting china or russia
china if i told you right now let's go
to moscow leningrad for a week for
vacation would you at all be worried
yeah i'd be a little worried about a
percentage
i get your point i'm just saying go to
china so let's go to china for we can do
vlog or do videos do some interviews
yeah you probably if i told you right
now hey you know uh the center of
houston rockets invited us with ns
cantor to go to
china to see how great the
i said how country
doing you'd probably take vacation that
week
you know what i'm saying you know
but the point being i think putin is
more reasonable so
who has incentives putin has to be good
with iran still not good but it's right
there so they're dealing they're between
caspian seeing them
everybody has to figure out a way to be
okay with that neighbor because it ain't
going away it's not like it's you're
living in a gated community there's a
terrible of a neighbor that is just a
mess and you're hoping one day they move
iran's not going to move countries in
the eu deal with them
and not not as uh
not
to the levels of because remember eu
individual countries to deal with iran
have to be
also held accountable to the other
countries in eu so you're almost one
major country so
i think it's very different than eu i
may be wrong than it would be in
countries that are closer to iran but
again i would tell you i think putin is
10 times more reasonable than she
is in china
do you agree yeah i would agree i think
you know for
from my standpoint both countries have a
level of
national pride that kind of trumps
everything else the way that the united
states used to have
you know and that's why they're they're
emerging as
i think you know countries that are
gonna eclipse us
sooner than later uh you could argue
that in a number of ways china already
has i think they're still dependent
enough on us
to where they they couldn't uh execute
certain things that they probably would
once they get to that point but
you know but both of them i think are
while they're hardline guys and their
you know the the pride and
success of their country is kind of the
the pinnacle of what they base all their
decisions off of
both of them are also not dumb enough or
or so emotional about those
those principles that they have that
they're that they're not willing to look
at it no different than you did with
iran like you have a i think a natural
bias to want to see the united states
get involved but your
your non-emotional side says no you need
to do it this way first you know whereas
most people wouldn't do that and i think
from a leadership standpoint in those
two countries that's that's necessary
and that's why they they do the business
deals that they do and are as successful
as they are and executing them
by the way it's uh china compared to
russia it's not even close
china is a 100x like what russia is in
every way exactly and i don't even know
what the other than oil industry what's
what kind of industry does russia have
other than oligarchy and oil but
but china has is
in many respects like you said mike is
going to surpass the united states keep
in mind they have 1.3 billion people
um russia
putin is way more has to be way more of
a
strategist you know xkgb
than
than uh i don't think she has to be i i
wouldn't i think they're both
very very capable in that regard yeah
but china is at least like you used this
analogy before if there's if there's a
poker hand china at least has a flush or
a straight putin's playing with like a
pair of threes and he's like pretending
that he's got you know pocket aces he
doesn't have the the the do you think he
has economy is one thing which you're
right if you want to show that real
quick title to validate uh
uh uh
adam's point david if you can put that
on the screen and zoom in even a little
bit more you see how big japan china is
japan is us is frances germany is italy
as uk is canada it's now find russia
i don't know their top ten and if they
are they're number ten or eleven bottom
right
you gotta zoom in more four o'clock
right zoom in looking right united
states 20 rushing all the way to the
right one point six five trillion four
times bigger than norway okay by the way
where's south korea on this
tiny little south korea
i don't know if you can find it yeah top
right okay one 1.82 trillion bigger than
russia bigger than russia a little less
south korea has a bigger generation
we'll now flip this now go to uh uh
military world leaders with nuclear
bombs world leaders they're top of the
list
but you got to realize i mean that's
that's like say something you know look
at that say something china and i click
on it too so you see the rest go a
little lower to see the rest see if
there's a leaders bulletin on there okay
check that out
all right so uh uh uh nuclear what do
you see uh uh u.s is at the top i'm
curious as to why they're at the top
because russia's both of russia's
numbers are higher go go that's not a go
go to another chart because this
wikipedia go to another one go back
go back there's another one that shows
it's a side go a little lower
there's one that shows you just go to
images i'm sure if you go to images
it'll give you a graph
click on the click on that one right
therearmscontrol.org let's see what that
is
uh go a little lower to see if they're
ranking it because there's a better site
that shows
there you
350. they're third but russia is 20
times more 18 times more than what china
is so
russia knows that they're decades ahead
by the time china catches in nuclear
warheads
you know world war iii may have taken
place by the time they try to catch up
you kind of have to ask yourself though
i mean at what point does it not even
matter i mean to me 350 50 nuclear
weapons is still enough to kill
everybody on the planet it's who's the
crazy enough guy that can pull the train
is this one of those things where the
the best defense is a good offense or
the best offense is a good defense where
it's like uh yeah i mean the the the
fact that uh you know that all these
numbers even exist is is proof of that
is that it's it's a deterrent uh you
know i also find it interesting the
united states is the only country that's
actually used them
you know um but you know so for us to
to meddle the way that we do i think uh
you know is is a little
a little uh convenient or strange but by
the way the the india pakistan situation
that's going on i don't know if you have
any stronger things they said that's the
most dangerous border in the world
they're both armed nuclearly and they
border each other and they are enemies
yeah no i mean i don't dispute that uh
from from that standpoint i mean i guess
the good news is it's at least there
you know uh as opposed to here not that
i'd want to see any any more nuclear
weapons being used but but you know i
think back to to pat's point is that
you know russia has a bigger thorn in
the side of of the entire world that way
you know like they're
they're more capable of causing bigger
problems i think at the drop of a hat or
in a
in a heated exchange more so than
probably china from a military
perspective for sure from a economic
perspective they are below
a tiny country like south korea i mean
even militarily outside of of the the
newt capacity
they're not that capable uh i mean
they're nowhere near as capable as the
united states or china you know it's
just it's the the nuclear stockpile and
that's kind of the great equalizer i
mean nuclear weapons are kind of the the
firearms of
of of countries that way uh if you
kind of parallel it to say a 70 year old
woman with a with a revolver i mean like
the nuclear weapons gives people a stage
that's why iran is so hell-bent on on
getting them is because it it enters you
into a realm of respect internationally
that just doesn't exist in any other way
mike do you have any aspirations of
getting involved in politics is this
something you're interested even a
little not even a little bit why not no
um for well for a couple of reasons i
mean one of the things i talk about in
my book is
the election process and and my my views
on how i would change that which i'm
happy to share but the
to me that there's an element of of even
wanting to run for any higher office i
think should automatically disqualify
you for it
how do you mean by that i think there's
a level of arrogance and narcissism and
bordering on there's got to be something
wrong with you to want to put you and
your family through the process that it
takes to get elected and the things that
you have to do
in terms of getting in bed and getting
donations and the deals that you have to
strike but by the time you get to that
point
i think you're so far removed from the
initial reasoning why you started it uh
that is why you see the the level of
corruption and bribery and lobbying that
exists in uh
in washington dc talk about your
election talk about what your ideas
would be in your book so
within the three branches of government
well let me let me take one step back is
that
you've got
um
you know we're so far gone to the point
where
a lot of people talk about you know
revolution or these huge
you know red flags as far as the nsa and
cia would be concerned or fbi you'd be
labeled a domestic terrorist for even
talking about it so
to to me that the happy medium is is
looking at the three branches of
government and saying which one is the
most influential
and from a checks and balances
standpoint the most in powerful to me
it's the legislative branch
the supreme court justices have to be
have to go through there they have the
ability to put checks and balances on
the president veto power executive order
etc
uh but the the problem is is that those
groups uh you know the the sub 500
number of people within the the congress
um you know are so heavily influenced by
that election process that nothing
really gets done the fact that every one
of them
gets into office and and are worth 10x
four years later is a huge problem and
so my take is no different than uh small
county texas of how they do grand jury
selection
is that i think that that you create a
a basic checklist of being a net
positive member of society you're up to
date on your taxes you're not a felon
you've lived in that that county or
region for x number of years uh you're a
net positive on society and and every
one of those people
have to come up with let's say five
names three names seven whatever
and then just like an election that the
tally comes in and your vote is on who
you think is the best person in that
county to represent that county on a
national level right and then so now at
that point whoever gets the most votes
uh for for that process now is is the
the delegate for that region and you
don't get a choice just like with jury
duty or being drafted in the military in
vietnam or whatever people may say well
that's unfair let's say it's a two-year
term we drafted hundreds of thousands of
people in vietnam fifty 000 of which
didn't even come home you know they
didn't get a choice on that jury duty
some some
uh trials last six eight months you know
and and you don't get a choice you have
you have to execute that and so i think
to have less than 500 people that are so
well liked by the the net positive
members of their community there's no
there's no finances involved there's no
hey you donated 2 million and so when i
get in office this you know
transport deal that's running through
our county is going to go to your
brother's construction company there's
none of that because none of that plays
a role in the initial
selection process once everybody is is
decided
now you you've got the the most accurate
legitimate representation of
of your society in the legislative
branch that's the entire representation
of of the entire nation
at that point you know those people
hopefully uh are are good enough to
where they didn't ask for it they were
voted in they they did it uh you know
kind of almost unwillingly as a civic
duty and so now they're the ones
deciding which justices get in they're
the ones deciding on on how to
check and balance the presidential
powers
is there going to be concerns or road
bumps with that i'm sure there would be
but to me
shy of completely wiping the whole thing
away i think that that's the
uh the quickest and most efficient way
to try to hit the reset button on on how
our country does its business so so if
that was the case who would have been
the president of the united states so so
it can't work for the president right it
can only work for local for local and
you know even statewide we'll say even
at a national level you know the
presidential thing
because of the the size of of how that
works would still have to be
uh
at least from my perspective still done
essentially how it's done
you know there's probably a hybrid
system people much smarter than me that
could come up with a way to to maybe
even
funnel funnel it through the legislative
branch at that point is that
you know maybe it's somebody that gets
selected from there as as uh or let's
say your your potential
candidates get selected from the
legislative branch so that now on a
national level it's at least one of
those people that that has
cleared through the check and balance of
of the local
local populace and it's not just some
[ __ ] that had aspirations to be
president from the time he was for and
dr eviled his way uh you know all the
way uh through it yeah one million that
would be that would be an interesting uh
way i do know like uh
i did a
whole video on how i would change the
voting system my voting system would be
slightly different you would have 10
votes
no my voting system is contribution to
society
that would be my vote yesterday bernie
sanders sent out a tweet
and he said something about call me
radical
uh
he said uh he said something about call
me radical but i believe that
um let me let me just pull it up and
read it to you
[Music]
call me radical but i happen to believe
that a job should lift workers out of
poverty not keep them in it a job should
lift people
out of poverty not keep them in it right
it depends on the job exactly depends on
the job so i turned around and i said
something different and you can call me
radical
and i said call me radical but i happen
to believe that america owes me nothing
the system of capitalism attracts good
talent 40 million immigrants had 200
other countries to choose from and they
chose america for a reason
no one forced immigrants to come here
they chose america works right so for me
i think
anybody that gets elected should have
the most contribution to society and the
way you contribute to societies in many
different ways the more you contribute
the more you
you know you know the same way how in
school somebody wanted to be a president
and you had to go do
you know uh what do you call it uh
um
volunteer work you had to do this you
had to do them same thing that he's
talking about who is like who's
contributing you contribute to get a
bigger vote you don't contribute you
don't get as big of a vote now this may
sound a little bit like well
how about the person that's going to be
taken advantage of there's exceptions to
the rule but anyways that's a complete
difference we talked on the podcast
before i want to transition to a
different topic will be goldberg let's
go to whoopi goldberg
um whoopi goldberg suspended from the
view for holocaust remarks this is a
variety
story okay this is a variety story
um whoopi goldberg has been suspended
from the view for two weeks after facing
white criticism for her remarks that the
holocaust was not about race goldberg
suspensions suspension was announced on
statement released by abc news public
relations tuesday night effectively
immediately i'm suspending we'll be go
over for two weeks for her wrong and
hurtful comments reads a statement
attributed to kim godwin president at
bbc while whoopi has apologized i've
asked her to take time to reflect and
learn about the impact of her comments
the entire abc news organization stands
in solidarity with our jewish colleagues
friends family and communities
goldberg's remarks emerged during a
conversation on monday's broadcast at
the view in which co-hosts discussed a
tennessee school boards bands of mouse a
non-fiction uh graphic novel about
cartoonist art spiegelman's father's
experience surviving the holocaust let's
be truthful about it because the holy
holocaust isn't about race said goldberg
this is white people doing it to other
white people the holy scholocause isn't
about race it's about a man's
inhumanity to man adam
i'm assuming you've seen her comments
and the banter back and forth what are
your thoughts yeah i um well this might
shock you i don't watch the view so it's
not like i know i know i
yeah i'm not a fan of uh
a whoopi or joy behar but
is there any
person who's more confused
than whoopi goldberg her last name is
goldberg that's pretty
jewy if you ask me
uh but yet she's not jewish but she kind
of hijacked the jewish name to kind of
be more palatable to hollywood i guess i
don't understand but she she's black but
not saying that you can't be black can't
be jewish but then i don't
she i think she's not a lesbian but she
kind of looks like one i don't know i
don't want to get cancelled but i don't
know what she's got going on
but
the naivete of her and the comments and
then
her co-host just kind of let sitting
back and letting her go deeper and
deeper and not being like hey whoopi do
you want to just kind of back up a
second
they just they they let her kind of hang
herself and they gave her the rope um
then
she went on colbert and doubled down on
the comments i don't know if you saw
that and colbert just kind of sat there
was like
okay coming up on break anything else
anything else and then i think someone
ultimately got to her and they were like
whoopi i don't know what the hell you're
doing or what thinking
but just shut up and read this script
and then she came out and she's like i
whoopi goldberg i do understand that
racism exists and you know these are my
words that i'm scripted so
again not a fan of the view i don't
watch the show this is sort of the
trickle-down effect of us hearing it by
hearsay but
what i will say about hitler is he
looked at at the jews as
not human
that was his whole thing
and as a jew
it's funny because i don't
know many jews who just consider
themselves to be just white
again
jews in general
you there's ashkenazi jews who are
basically uh that's me out of the
eastern europe poland russia finland
germany that area of country then
there's sephardic jews out of morocco
the middle east iran for an example and
then there's ethiopian jews they're
basically you know just south of israel
in the middle east
so
to be jewish is not just a religion it's
a culture it's an ethnicity
it's
it's it's sort of all-encompassing i
don't know many jews that even if
they're white are like yeah i'm just a
white guy
um
there is something unique about being
jewish and
the
her comments were what exactly the
holocaust isn't about race it's about
all that
it's about inhumanity it's about race
it's about ethnicity it's about white
power white supremacy judaism arianism
uh
it's never good to start making these
types of comments and this is an example
why now i'm glad
that she's not
canceled for good she's what suspended
for two weeks should she be cancer i do
not think she should she'd be fired i do
not think she should what did roseanne
barr say
when she got fired what did roseanne say
when she got fired i'm curious
oh and she said uh what did roseanne say
she obviously made some
what was her comment when she got fired
right there tweet roseanne barr uh uh
right there
show us being killed and she talked
about valerie jarrett and looking kind
of like a monkey or something like an
ape
is that what it was can you figure out a
way to find that the tweet just you know
just go to images just go to images
it'll show the tweet is this what it's
like when he drives as you guys barking
orders
you know what it is this is like go left
no no go right so it's probably just as
frustrating on tyler as it is on us but
think about it just from before we find
this tweet click on that oh you got it
yeah let's see
uh i apologize to valerie no no i don't
know that's not apologetic
the main one look at the
um
muslim brotherhood muslim
had a baby it was valerie jarrett
exactly what do you what do you think
about is that uh fireball offense look
man i think
we're so a comedian saying that would
you say roseanne's a comedian i don't
yes
uh a non-funny one but yeah she i agree
but she's a comedian right so she made a
comment like that which by the way
that's a stupid
comment to make like she was also on the
sleeping pills i forget what they're
called whatever you're on though but
that's a dumb comment to make okay
there's nothing about this that to me
it's funny that's not funny to me when i
hear that right now if somebody thinks
it's funny it is what it is and what
whoopi said
obviously she's she wasn't trying to be
funny she was just now she talked like
she believed what she was talking about
what's funny is whippy used to be a
comedian i don't know if anyone would
define her as a comedian not today she's
too serious she's too bitter yeah she
made her upset i don't know what's going
on with her but think about this for a
second here's the reason that that
you know we talk about joe rogan being
canceled i think more than anything the
first amendment
it doesn't it it's not there for the
speech you want to hear it's for the
speech that you don't want to hear and
that's the whole point of the first
amendment and just the the knee-jerk
reaction to cancel somebody
at the very least
now you can learn and people around you
can learn you know like
this is a off topic but remember when
michael vick
was basically removed from the nfl by
the way that's another one for changing
your reputation he's actually shown back
in the media that's my point
is that you can learn and get smarter
and better and improve that's what
sharon stone said and now he's really
and now he's an advocate
for dogs i mean i'm sure this is this
this is something that probably hits
close to home for you and not dog
fighting by the way can you do me a
favor type in sharon stone cancel
culture she may have explained cancer
culture better than
anybody else i've heard sharon stone out
of everybody uh
okay click on that so we can read it uh
uh uh make it uh see if you can find
your comments according to
she believes if someone says something
or behaves in a way that you are
displeased with you can always try and
understand each other you can learn to
respect each other's opinion on
different matters she further explained
that people have struggled and done so
much
for you to cancel the person all because
they
did something you are not happy with go
lower uh go lower goal or to read the
rest of it yeah no she didn't just
express her opinions on the sake of
internet validation for the sake of
going against wanted to want some
profound reaction
anyways she she keeps continuing going
saying how are we supposed to learn of
each other if we don't argue how are we
supposed to learn more about each other
where you say something i'm offended
with i got to go do the research right
the part that here becomes the concern
is the following i got a question i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
so what is a bigger crime okay what is a
bigger crime what is more offensive
is it a bigger crime to ask
tough questions everyone's thinking
about or is it a bigger crime to make
dumb statements
what's a bigger crime is it a bigger
crime for me to ask
uh
you know someone a direct question uh
you're dating and you're sitting are you
getting to the point that you're
thinking about you know maybe i'm gonna
call this guy my you know boyfriend or
girlfriend is it dumber to say hey let
me ask you a question last two
relationships how come they didn't work
out looks like both of them left you why
did they leave you okay that's a tough
question or is it worse to say you're
such a dog
okay
what's what's worse
to me to me it's honestly neither as it
relates to both that that question and
and these is that
i think we're where the majority of of
society who gets up in arms on either
side of the table on stuff like this
can't differentiate between something
that they don't like and something that
legitimately harms them
and i think that that's the the
benchmark that everybody should try to
adhere to when it comes to stuff like
this i don't think anybody should be
canceled or fired or whatever for stuff
like this especially when
it's somebody who is in in the media you
know if you're a comedian you're an
entertainer you're a big personality on
social media whether it's twitter or you
have your own radio show or whatever it
is is that you are out there in the
public expressing your opinions and
views and people have the ability to
just not [ __ ] watch if they if they
don't like it i mean to me the nfl is
the same way uh you know taking a knee
or some of the other controversies that
they've had is that i i don't think it
should be outlawed does it piss me off
it does but i have the choice to either
watch the nfl or not watch the nfl and i
think it's the same with the view i
think it's same with comedians i think
it's same with listening to joe rogan to
me with all this stuff it's really that
black and white is is that it's either
all or nothing you know you either
decide we're going to dictate what
everybody can say and and then we don't
have a democracy of freedom freedom of
speech anything or or you don't and you
let people do what they're going to do
and you choose to listen or not i'll
take a different angle with this one
okay i'll take a different angle with
the small world whoopi okay
i think we'll be so necessary for media
i think she is so necessary
i think a lot of people don't like her
but i think whoopi needs to be there
because whoopi
is uh pushing buttons to get others to
sit there and say what the hell is she
talking about i think she needs to stay
i think whoopi the way she handled mel
gibson when mel gibson made the comments
this wasn't 2010 or 2011 when the view
that's a long time ago type in mel
gibson uh the view whoopee and see what
year comes up it could have been 2010
2011.
and she said look i i don't know what
happened there but here's what i can
tell 2010 when she made i could write
whoopi defense goldberg 2010 go to the
bottom one cbs news yeah when she
defended we'll pick over defense mel
gibson on the view okay so go up and if
you guys remember this was not like a
says i don't like what he did here but i
know mel and i know he's not racist the
view on the monday he may be a bonehead
i can't sit and say that he's a racist
having spent time with him in my house
with my kids
if someone's kicking your behind and
punching you while you're holding your
kid you don't go to the cops first you
go to raider online goldberg said
anyways
so you know mel made a few comments
and she defended him okay she just kind
of came out and said i don't know and
then by the way there was another guy
who was a very big actor he was on there
as well full-on republican he was on the
view
and he disagrees with whoopi so i think
whoopi has friends on the opposing side
but i just think she made a very
bonehead uh mistake with the comments
you make and you have to realize that
hollywood is ran by
jews so you you're making a comment to
the point where a lot of these
executives you know the whole history of
hollywood started by who so you you just
got to be very careful with some of the
comments you're making but i don't think
she needs to be canceled i think she
needs to stay on the view on but knowing
what's going on today
if i'm a betting man i'm leaning more
towards her getting fired than her not
getting fired you're shaking your head
for a minute we didn't think cuomo was
gonna get fired he did for a minute we
didn't think zucker would ever get fired
he did for a moment we thought chris
chroma would never get fired he did
these are all people on the left by the
way so so to have your own selective
hearing conservative side to say they
would never fire her they would keep her
i think they're probably leaning towards
firing her i hope they don't but what's
the benefit of firing whoopi i we did it
we got rid of her
dumb comments will no longer happen like
you're never going to create a safe
space
and that you're never going to create
this echo chamber that everybody gets to
hear everything that they want and no
disagreement and no arguments that's the
whole point of what we're doing here in
america is that we're never gonna always
get along but talk it out figure it out
and if everyone just doesn't feel safe
to say what's on their mind now we're
not
basically living under the first
amendment and it's freedom of speech and
now it's like you're walking on
eggshells i don't want to say that here
are my thoughts and then it just becomes
a china thing or an iran thing where you
can't even say what's on your [ __ ]
mind that's crazy and the best thing
that will come after this whoopee thing
just like the michael vick thing is that
she'll learn from it and that people
will be like whoopee you gotta
understand that this and it should
and and only progress will happen from
this not saying what's on your mind no
progress will happen you know the jewish
holocaust museum reached out to her to
say we'd like to invite you to simon
wiesenthal
yeah us
we would love to invite you to come here
let us share with you the history
i think if whoopi goes there and she
shows the effort i think that's a great
example for americans i wonder if they
addressed it as dear mrs goldberg would
you like to
the irony here
oh my gosh uh okay so let's go to the
story where this leads me to the next
story there's this guy i don't know if
you follow his content his name is joe
rogan
and he never heard him yeah he he does
he talks and he asks questions and
some people follow his content
not that many like he's a big deal 11
million to 50 million people
kind of a big deal
and he kind of beats everybody in
mainstream media and uh
yeah by a lot and they're not happy
about it stelter what's his name brian
stelter who cannot stand
uh rogan but let me kind of give you an
idea what's going on with saki yesterday
okay so first i'll read the spotify
story then i'll go to the sake story
spotify responds to joe rogan uproar on
growing trend and controversial content
this is a polygon story if you want to
go to page
four page four so
um
last week after season of open letters
to spotify imploring the streaming audio
side to cut host joe rogan loose from
its podcast roster over accidental
related misinformation legendary music
legend
musician neil young voluntarily removed
his music from the platform the uproar
caused by young's protest prompted
spotify to finally issue statement on
sunday on january 30 and a blog post
credited to spotify founder daniel ek uh
spotify announced that it was working to
add a content advisory to any podcast
episode that includes a discussion with
kova 19 which when implemented direct
listeners to kovit hub
where they can find updates from bbc
political cnn and other mainstream news
outsources look at the num names they
took bbc political cnn all left-leaning
a decade ago we created spotify to
inevitable work of creators around the
world to be heard and enjoyed by
listeners around the world
to our very core we believe that
listening is everything pick almost any
issue you will find most people's
opinions on either side personally there
are plenty of individuals and viewers on
spotify that i disagree with strongly we
know we have a critical role to play in
supporting creator expression while
balancing it with the safety of our
users if that critical if that in that
role it is important to me that we don't
take any position
of being content sensors
while also making sure that there are
rules in place and consent consequences
for those who violate them okay so now
here's a kicker adam this is the one
that i was telling about earlier spotify
initially announced in response and
young that
the company had great responsibility in
balancing both safety for listeners and
freedom of creators and had removed 20
000 podcast episodes related to kovitz
since the start of the pandemic but
after the episode purge spotify left up
gre 1757 with dr robert malone whose
claims of mass societal hypnosis
in comparisons of the pandemic response
to holocaust prompted over 200 medical
professionals etc etc so
that's spotify's position then saki
comes out and i'll get your thoughts
ginsaki cheer spotify warning on kovalev
podcast says more should be done new
york post story white house press
secretary jensecki plotted spotify
tuesday for adding a disclaimer to
podcast episode cover 19 before adding
there's more that can be done the new
spotify warning will link
we talked about that this disclaimer is
a positive sped step but we want every
platform to continue
doing more to call out miss and
disinformation while also uplifting
accurate information
our view is it's a good step it's a
positive step and there's more that can
be done thoughts
i think the white house should stay out
of it i don't think they should have a
position on it and i think that they
should let companies run their business
how they run their business especially
when it has to deal with
censorship in the first amendment i
think if anything they should they
should champion and
applaud you know companies for for
allowing
platforms that uh that let people say
what they want to say
you know that um
rogan uh has a point or he has
he stands on fertile ground
when you have left-leaning people saying
yeah i don't agree with this guy but do
not cancel this dude i.e howard stern
i.e joy behar from the view they have
all come out and basically said look
like i think joy behar basically called
him a [ __ ] which i i believe me i think
everyone would agree that of the two we
know which one is the [ __ ] and it's not
rogan but howard stern who
for whatever reason has sprinted left
but if there's anybody that's an
advocate for freedom of speech it's
freaking howard stern that guy has been
people don't understand these days as
big as rogan is now howard stern was 10
times bigger than that for a decade yeah
okay
now rogan clearly is the king of all
media i think howard stern labeled
himself the king of all media but even
howard stern came out and said i don't
agree with rogan i would agree with some
of the stuff he talks about in his
podcast specifically the covet stuff but
do not cancel this man yeah and this
goes back to our first point is just
just because people are saying the
things that make you uncomfortable or
may not even be true
is that
grounds for dismissal and cancel no i i
mean again i think uh this whole
canceling thing is a
is a snowball off the rails turning into
an avalanche you know
anytime you cancel anybody it takes a
notch of of liberty out of the country
in my opinion you just got to let people
do what they're going to do and again
i'll beat the dead horse and say you you
have to differentiate between not liking
something and legitimately being hurt by
it there's a huge difference right and
pat i mean we've talked about this
numerous times you were on rogan you've
you've had a a great experience there
you have your own podcast right now we
have aspirations of being as big as
rogan one day um how does this make you
feel with everything that's happening
with him right now he's the most
necessary voice in the world today in
america today period rogan is the most
necessary voice in america today listen
let me put it to you this way
everybody better protect this guy
because if he you know some people are
saying well he's kind of also being
bullied to not talk about it was like
hey he's going to go back to only
talking about hallucinogen you know
mushrooms and aliens and all that and
he's going away from covet right they're
kind of pulling him for him to be
silenced in a way
you have to know that is a very very
necessary guy but here's the big butt
this is the big bot
and it's what i said to rogan when i
went on the podcast with him
and i i was doing my best to get him to
think about this and i think it's
actually going to happen to be honest
with you i think it's going to happen
i think
here's what i'm convinced
say spotify they went from a 70 billion
dollar company a year and a half ago
the market hasn't tanked
they've lost they went from a 60 billion
dollar company to a 36 billion dollar
company they've lost 24 billion dollars
almost cut in half since signing rogan
okay now this is not a rogan thing
they've just lost that much during that
time
neil young alone they lost four billion
on this one guy and if all these other
guys show up they lose money now let me
give you a completely different aspect
uh perspective on this
let's say
spotify do what do you think of the
chance of spotify drop in rogan give me
a percentage
no i don't zero no it's not zero you
can't say zero this is i don't i think
there would be you cannot say zero such
insane backlash give me another spot
give me the number
less than two percent you think it's
less than two percent what do you think
canceling rogan to me to me i'm gonna
put it at 50 if they're losing that
amount of money so here we go okay yeah
i think it's ten percent i don't think
it's 50 but i'm 10 okay 2 50 40 10
fine here's the thing let's say they do
it let's go there
okay
spotify if you're listening to this
let's say you go there okay well no no
actually go there i'm there i'm there
because you're gonna see where you're
gonna see if this happens what happens
go ahead and cancel rogan
what who's the first person that's going
to call rogan
give me the first person that's going to
call roman apple music no absolutely
nope no no any major meaning no company
one person's going to call rogan it's
the first phone call if rogan gets
canceled elon musk elon musk is going to
call royalties
elon musk is going to call rogan saying
here's 20 billion dollars
let's go whoop everyone's ass then
elon's gonna say we're hiring for
engineers
me and rogan have teamed up with peter
thiel we're hiring engineers we're
hiring developers we're giving big-ass
bonuses and equity come on down let's
whoop everyone's ass
and that's to be elon rogen and theo who
do you think is going to go on that
website
an elon musk they just called them jv of
evie
biden said jv of evie they're not even
inviting him to the white house again
and and elon musk if you see elon musk
what he said about biden this last week
i don't know if you saw what ilama said
about biden this is not favorable no of
course it's not favorable because you're
talking about tesla when you think about
ev
you know
when you think about ev you think about
uh like you must only say who what other
names do you think about you
you know think about nobody else no and
by the way somebody said ximena said
donald trump i disagree that's not the
right guy to bring behind it because
that would not help the cause i think
it's elon musk rogan peter thiel
if spotify drops him so here's the thing
why would why would a elon musk need a
peter thiel you know peter thiel oh my
gosh you must not know who peter thiel
is i know who he is but why would elon
need him you don't need him but you need
them okay because peter thiel is a true
believer and again here's a guy that's a
gay libertarian who has strong beliefs
but has everything in silicon valley all
roads lead to peter thiel you don't
peter thiel mafia he's an underground
tough guy brilliant guy you don't mess
with that guy that guy's a genius you
put those three together then guess what
everybody's doing everyone's shivering
everybody is shaking if those three guys
back up so so to me
i do think like right now how old is
rogan today rogan's how old he's i say
he's early he's 50 53 okay how old is uh
stern
rogan is what he's got
he's 54. okay how old is stern go stern
age i'm guessing 66.
uh
his age is what 68. okay you're by the
way he just signed like a 10-year
contract and he's 16. he's going to go
to 78. okay would you say rogan's a
young 54 year old can we say rogan's a
young 54 year old okay so watch this
watch this watch this
so rogan musk is what 50
yes musk is also around the same age so
if these guys teamed up
and they started recruiting people
it would be game over
so so there is a side there is a side
that
i dare spotify to do something i dare i
double dare you elon would make it a
mission of his to go out there and do
this it would be bad news for a lot of
people in silicon valley and spotify it
would be great news for free thinkers
for entrepreneurs for those that just
want to sit there and say i disagree
with you can we sit down and have a
conversation have some banter that's
what i think so the concern about if if
if joe you know by himself not wife's
not around girls are not around
daughters are not around friends are not
around
joey's not around all these other people
are not on that he talks to regularly
he's by himself you're in the car by
yourself driving your security nobody's
around you he's sitting there and it's
like
man what if spotify drops me
okay
i would say
i dared him to drop me
it would be more from that perspective
because then
right now he's got a lot of followers
now you're going to go into
you know legendary
no no no it's game over type of let you
talking about now you have a world type
of influence at the next level because
now you dictate now ilan you know joe's
gonna be like okay let me get a handful
of these guys that i
like their strategies let's go recruit
what do you think that phone calls sound
like hey i'm joe rogan i noticed you
have a podcast we like to have you come
to xyz company with me elon musk
so so yeah i i i imagine that yeah i by
the way i
i don't know why i want to see that
so do i i want to see that you know how
that idea starts by the way how it's
just them too on a podcast one big fat
ass joint elon musk taking a hit
we are recruiting people if you want to
be in text us at this number here's a
link go subscribe
let's start so i don't know so to me
you know
people have to protect joe and i think
elon in a way is a protector of ideas i
think elon and a handful of other people
who are very powerful in their own way
boom let's go and they're going to go
elon actually has those types of
aspirations to putting together
the guy wants to go marry aliens
according to what you want to say he was
going to live on mars so so if he wants
to go on mars this this
what's harder living on mars or kicking
everyone's ass in silicon valley i'm
sorry it's living on mars this is
nothing to them it's chump change
i think that they they could do that or
that that's a possibility that that's
not going to influence whether or not
spotify drops them i think they're going
to look at it purely as a business move
is that if it gets to the point where
enough people say if you don't drop them
we leave and and their bottom line gets
to a certain number then they'll get rid
of them just based on that you're kind
of irrespective of what they think but
is there number hemorrhaging because of
rogan that can't be the reason i mean
i'm sure it's impossible to quantify i
have no doubt that there's a lot of uh
factors to it but
you know to me
again like at some point if they just
continue to lose and lose and i mean i'm
i'm still sitting here a little bit
reeling from the fact that that uh neil
young cost him 4 billion by leaving how
the [ __ ] is that even possible
uh
spotify lost 4 billion from him type it
in put neil young 4 billion spotify to
me that's surprising i guess but uh i
i'd be shocked if people under 30 even
knew who neil young was i mean but and
that's the thing right spotify like if
you look at a lot of older musicians
like they have very small followings on
there most of them look at that right
there
spotify loses 4 billion in market value
after nearly on controversy that's crazy
yeah so so you think it's not an impact
it's an impact so i guarantee the board
there's no way we're not looking at that
the board has got so much pressure
listen
listen i'm telling you right now joe
ilan peter i'm telling you
two to three have plenty of experience
running companies going up against
bigger enemies i mean tesla went up
against who's a bigger mafia than ford
gm chrysler toyota tell me who's a
bigger mafia
who is a bigger mafia you go take their
lunch
are you kidding me this guy took their
this is no joke this is not an easy
industry to take their lunch you're
talking about that guy he didn't say let
me create a new website called
facebook and let's go create something
new he said what does everybody use a
car let me go make cars what
and beat everybody that's that's hard
that this is not hard that's hard so
yeah so if this keeps happening stuff
like this let me make your job easier
for you spotify i resign okay
you paid me 100 million dollars no
problem elon's willing to pay me a
billion dollars elon will sign a 1
billion 20-year contract with joe rogan
that's what he would do in a heartbeat
hey joe
50 million a year for 20 years do the
podcast on my show that's what elon
would do okay and 50 million a year to
elon musk is what it's like you going to
starbucks okay he ain't even gonna feel
it okay he's gonna say joe don't worry
about it drop spotify send a letter
resignation it's become too much of a
frustration let's go whoop some ass
together everybody would be shedding
bricks
everybody would be calling their mommy
saying mommy you will not believe joe oh
my gosh what do we do everybody would be
in tears saying this is the one guy
crazy enough that can pull it off that
is the one guy
because
when you when you push when you push
true believers
who are the best at what they do who are
number one not complainers that quit and
then they say i'm jo you ain't joe bro
you're like number you know when
somebody leaves a company and i'm gonna
go do i'm gonna be the next joke no no
no there's only one joe in the world
there's only one elon musk in the world
if that happens
game over oh my god
do you know what that's like frazier
against ali forget about it
trump hillary forget about it i mean who
do you want to put in there big magic
against jordan 1990 1991 forget about it
you know jordan against pistons forget
about it this is gonna be
the underdogs against the bullies let's
go bully the hell out of the bullies
these are the guys that are the ragtag
people that are showing up
let's go it would be freaking
entertainment at the highest level now
maybe i'm just dreaming yeah
that just went you went somewhere with
that by the way you're on fire right now
but i tell you i don't want you to stop
but i tell you but i tell you but i'm
telling you right now i fully tell you
right now
the biggest insurance policy
is being
a worker
is being fair
is being a chill guy that people like
it's being humble yet competitive and
deliver on the product willing to
constantly improve you track the right
people in your life this morning i did a
video about talking about the biggest
currency to invest into more than
bitcoin more than ethereum more than any
stock more than gold more than anything
there's nothing
more valuable than b everybody wants to
get some more bitcoin in their net in
their wallet or whatever it is yeah
there is no currency more valuable than
your attitude
your attitude no currency more valuable
than your attitude your attitude is why
you're here
you and i met at an insurance event for
eight years we didn't do nothing every
year i saw you're at it i'm like what i
can't wait to meet that guy what's the
guy i don't know his name but i like
meeting this guy adam what's up
and hey this is adam hey let me add them
you got to do content
your attitude is the most expensive
currency you have money
that's fine you have crypto that's fine
your attitude is worth 20 times more
than all the one you got in the world
look at joe's attitude it's freaking
attractive look at elon's attitude it's
attractive and some people don't like
attractive attitude that attitude is
worth billions forget the 100 million
dollar contract you can't teach joe's
attitude that attitude is very very
attractive
and the attitude you know what's the
best thing about a great attitude you
know what's the great thing about a big
ad what business are you and i earned
what industry are we insurance financial
services there is not a bigger insurance
policy than a great attitude
because you're protected for the rest of
your life because your attitude who can
take your attitude away from you
it's yours
every organization every company every
city every state every country wants
people with better attitudes it goes
back to your voting system in your book
that you talk about where the 500 people
and the people that have done most for
that it's what it's a form of an
attitude you want to contribute to your
society yeah to the society you live in
so yeah i mean they're not gonna they're
not gonna nominate people with shitty
attitudes no they're not you know
they're just not gonna do it and by the
way we're not gonna bring somebody back
on our podcast with a shitty added to
three times your attitude is freaking
awesome you know it goes to you
you know your attitude is sick everybody
every time you come here it's attractive
there's something here's a navy seal
that if you wanted to could go out there
and do a lot of harm to people just the
chill guy you're talking to laughing
chopping it up different kind of
conversation so i don't know more and
more i'm getting excited about this more
and more i i kind of want to see this
happen yeah as you went there you
started 10 are you bumping it up no no
i'm 10 that spotify will drop
but i tell you
the biggest bad ass move would
be oh
so you're 10 percent on spotify dropping
rogan but but where are you at on rogan
saying like you said i don't need rogan
sees this i'm done i'm going to go i'm
going to send a message tomorrow
rarely send just watch this and just
please consider it joe just please
consider it okay just please consider it
i'm telling you and elon
you're watching this
sign a billion dollar contract with joe
for 20 years
you can do it i bet he'd do it for free
by the way no no joe wouldn't do it joe
doesn't need to do it for free because
joe's attitude and the way he does
things is it's worth a billion dollars
minimal
if if i was running a media company
joe's a billion dollar 20-year contract
joseph minimum i'm not even telling you
hi alone that's a minimum joe's a 50
million dollar a year guy for 20 years
and by the way this isn't like i'm
trying to get on rogan this isn't like
how some people like oh people say good
things about you because they want to
get our work and i was out on the road
can you wait a great time
yeah no i'm saying this because i'm
telling you joe's a billion dollar net
worth attitude and ilan needs to come
out and say i'm signing
a 20 or 1 billion dollar contract with
joe for joe to do his podcast on the
network that i'm creating i think that's
what needs to happen and that is the
biggest power move oh my
people would by the way check this out
watch this now watch this now
uh this friday i'm having a meeting with
uh a very powerful ceo of a major social
media company that you all know about
he's coming here we're gonna have dinner
together today's wednesday or what is
today today is thursday tomorrow night
yeah
maybe we'll go to dinner as well so it's
tomorrow night right um
trump starts in that the truth network
who's going to join the network
who
do you think you do
alex jones do you think aoc is going to
be on that network no no but she needs
to be okay if she's wants to do a debate
but not really but watch this if elon
and joe and peter thiel
started network who would be on that
everybody left right center up down i
don't know i don't think aoc would be
but here's who would be if this is alex
jones
if this is aoc and uh uh young turks and
who else you want to put in your bernie
yeah
everybody guys if this is center these
guys would be on 82 of america i think
these guys will be on the people that
matter would be on yeah 100 but i think
if trump does it i think only these guys
will be on okay what's crazy is they're
painting joe rogan to be out some like
right and like far right he's he said he
would vote for bernie yeah
on camera said he would vote for bernie
i mean to me that that's just grasping
at straws trying to trying to discredit
him because they don't have anything
else to do with the dumbest thing that
cnn and these people on the left can do
is try to go after rogan yeah i agree
you know sanjay gupta to his respect
went on rogan and answered some time
but
but respect to him for going for sure
agreed i mean that's how it needs to
happen and again that's why
you know my take on sake in the white
house having a position on it i think is
a mistake you know it just makes them
look bad i mean
historically look at any government that
tried to censor its citizens has always
been the [ __ ] bad guy always like
that that's never a good thing ever you
know so for them to do that i think is
is a huge misstep and i i just i don't
get it
i mean that the same
uh pr guy or whoever is is trying to
advise the president on on actions to
take to pull his head out of his ass
image-wise needs to do the same thing
with their with their money remember
there was a very famous clip this was
during the george w bush years when i
believe the press secretary was ari
fleischer yeah and he was talking about
bill maher and he goes bill maher needs
to be very careful what he's saying
these days nobody appreciates
uh you know the thing now bill maher
other than rogan one of the more
unnecessary voices in america and
where's arie fleischer these days to
your point mike ritland
when the government goes after people to
silence them never good luck can i can i
throw one other thing in there yeah
yes sir yeah
so who just resigned who just resigned
uh cnn cnn jeff zucker just resigned
which let me for say cnn worldwide
present president jeff zucker the
influential news executive who reshaped
the iconic network this
cnn wrote this article about so i'm
reading it so the way they wrote it
and who reshaped the iconic network
abruptly announced wednesday morning
that he has resigned from his position
in fact immediately as part of the
investigation to chris como's 10-year
tnn i was asked about a consensual
relationship my closest colleague
someone had worked with for more than 20
years i acknowledged the relationship
evolved in recent years i was required
to disclose it when it began but i
didn't i was wrong as a result i'm
resigning today that's not why yeah
zucker did not name his colleague in the
memo but the relationship is with
allison golos the chief marketing
officer for cnn she is still staying
with cnn so watch this
okay
let's throw so you know how you go to a
restaurant you first order your drink
i'd like to have a you know arnold
palmer they bring the orange sorry we're
out of lemonade
every time
we do like some salad i'll take i'll
take some prodigy salad with some
balsamic glaze on the side fantastic
thank you would you like to do some
appetizers yes i'll have some
fried zucchini flowers and some uh you
know
steak
tartare some oysters some oysters and a
full gra and some bone marrow no problem
no boneless buffalo strips
that's coming back now you know where my
eats and where patties are
fridays
potato wedges
can we get some mesquite chicken all
right so i'm gonna go with that rather
yes with that
would you like some dessert yes i'll
take some whatever dessert with sundae
or you know sorbet whatever they bring
dessert here you know what the dessert
would be here
if elon went and bought cnn
oh my god
if ilan says i'm gonna buy cnn that
would be amazing if something like that
were to happen if you were to say i'm
gonna cut a check
and buy cnn
people
would would lose it okay and by the way
if they bought cnn overnight you would
see all the airports they would no
longer show cnn it would be msnbc yeah
for sure why do you think the airport
they're not gonna let elon have control
to show
uh uh that would scare the crap out of
them that scared the crap out of him if
he did something like do the airports
have some sort of arrangement with cnn
is that is that their
the airport show cnn that's that's right
i mean is that is that just the airports
majority of airports show cnn if you go
to texas they'll have cnn and fox
what's the story behind that in florida
they show nickelodeon that's what they
show
but in new york and i don't want to tell
you what new york shows you know shows a
whole different uh perspective but yeah
it's mainly
a lot of
cnn what are your thoughts on what
happened here with uh zunker what was
the real story here oh i think cuomo got
him fired
specifically cuomo i absolutely believe
cuomo got him fired why why because
zucker threw coma under the bus
so you don't remember when it first came
out and it's like zucker yeah we have to
let cuomo go and then
cuomo was like wait a minute no no you
ain't gonna make me look like an idiot
my father's mario cuomo we don't let the
bully bully us
no here's what we're going to be doing
this is exactly what you did as well and
then zucker got fired so zucker got
fired
by the person he fired chris cuomo can i
read a quote yeah as part of the
investigation into chris cuomo's tenure
here at cnn i was asked about a
consensual relationship with my closest
colleague someone i've worked with for
more than 20 years zucker just told
employees in a memo i acknowledge the
relationship evolved in recent years i
was required to disclose it when it
began
but i didn't
i was wrong as a result i'm resigning
today soccer did not name his colleague
in the memo but relationship with
allison
golist the chief marketing officer for
cnn
is remaining at cnn
so what's your what's just
apparently inappropriate work
relationships or not even inappropriate
not disclosing it i mean there's no way
that that took place for 20 years and
everybody didn't know about it everybody
had to know that he was banging alice
yeah to me there's there's just got to
be more to it i mean how about the fact
that they've lost 90 percent of their
viewers how does that not not play some
role in this has to be well i you know
look
but by the way just think about it think
about it what network did trump call
fake news
santa so just did you see trump's
comment about cnn did you see trump's
comment about zucker did you read it or
no yeah why don't you pull out what
trump said about the
zucker getting fired and he wrote out a
memo while you're pulling it up i have
it here so i'll just read it
jeff sugger jeff zucker a world-class
sleazeback who has headed ratings and
and real news challenge cnn for too long
for far too long has been terminated for
numerous reasons or predominantly
because cnn has lost its way with
viewers and everybody else now it's a
chance to put fake news in the backseat
because there may not be anything more
important than straightening out the
horrendous
lame stream media in our country and in
this case of cnn throughout the world
jeff zucker is gone congratulations to
all okay
that's your uh that's your guy saying
that you were at his place yesterday
right i was at trump uh can i brought
you some gifts appreciate it if kai's
listening i would love him to
to bring in the gifts that i brought for
pat but by the way i don't know if this
is a
a left or right thing
because this is just a power thing
there's two things going on here cnn's
ratings are in the tank i'm sure you
want to transition to maybe the tunker
story which is applicable here but this
is a powerful thing this happened to
roger ailes this happened to bill
o'reilly this happened to charlie rose
this happened to matt lauer this
happened to chris cuomo whether it's
harvey weinstein even this is a power
move you're you're if you're the head of
a network or the face of a network
you've got the power you've got the
money
everything that happened with roger
ailes is applicable here to jeff zucker
and where you know when you're the guy
in charge and you see a pretty little
marketing lady over there you're gonna
step into my office do a little twirl
let's see the outcome is that how it
goes
allegedly i don't know
so i i mean to me i'm i'm sure that
there's more of the story i think to
your point with uh it being cuomo
there's probably going to be more more
to come out of it too like he's not
he's obviously pissed and taking the
ship with him or at least trying i i
would bet that you'll see more
more backlash and and maybe even more
people either quitting or getting fired
you fire your best guy and then you
trash him
no man you can't you can't do that do
you remember when we talked about cnn
thinking about they're bringing in chris
wallace yeah because they're getting
bought out by this guy john malone and
he he can't stand cnn he's a serious
person with serious goals who has and he
said quote he wants to bring it back to
actual journalism can you show this
picture by the way with tyler simon
discovery board member john malone
uh
lauds fox news before saying he wants
cnn to evolve back to actual journalism
and i don't want to say i called this a
couple months ago but
yeah it's because of this new owner he
he wants actual journalism he
understands that cnn is a joke and as
you guys say it's ratings now why
they're going with but ratings sucks so
their strategy is not working that's why
he wants to switch it and he's kicking
out jeff sucker why they went with that
for the excuse
to tell me you mean to tell me como
didn't fire zucker because yeah i mean
this argument you're saying the backlash
from cuomo
oh i'm here's what happened with cuomo
cuomo probably made a phone call and he
said listen
here's what you guys want to do to me
you want to ruin my reputation and hurt
my family just know that's not the right
move and i don't appreciate that and
then boom i led to a conversation
together with them and obviously the
rest is history yeah because that
article was from mid-november
this is two hours ago from insider cnn
suspect chris cuomo flag jeff zucker's
workplace relationship has revenge there
you go and i don't even i this is when
this is when we just went live on the
podcast this is two hours ago yeah so
get out of here no inside oh here's kai
with the the the gifts that i brought
you
how was it spending time with trump how
how was it for you he's a huge fan of
the podcast okay good huge fan
um you know what he basically said was
like listen it's possible for us to
disagree without being disagreeable i
said thanks don i really appreciate that
i have i missed my uh invitation to
mar-a-lago but i appreciate all the
goodie bags and gifts that you gave me
and this is what i wanted to give to you
thank you wow so
by the way
here we go it's a i feel like i want to
get there's something
is a trump hotels yup bag right here
here we go
laundry bag now
now obviously save that money i didn't
spend money on this
i
took it from
my hotel room but i noticed something
he's going to come find and i wanted to
get your take on this so here are a lot
of goodies from
us the trump fun hotel room now what i
wanted to get your opinion on was this
now these are just a ton these are
shampoo these are conditioners these are
lotions these are
q-tips these are hand lotions this is
everything this is everything and i
ironically i wanted to bring you this
anyway this was not the point of this i
was like let me get some trump stuff but
here's what i was like holy [ __ ] i need
to get pat's opinion on look on the
bottom made in china every single one of
these things it says made in china
every
single one of these things read that
right there what's it say on the top
right there made in china i'm thinking
this how is this possible i'm at trump
property
doral miami his amazing golf course and
i'm showering i'm getting ready i'm
stealing gifts to get the pat and they
all say made on china made in china how
is that possible shampoo how is that
possible for everything he's done
against china and respect for him from
calling them out
this is not a good look
i'm surprised it's not more popular or
like the more people don't know about it
are you are you
are you surprised are you i'm a little
surprised i'm like i'm a little
heartbroken
okay i got you i was genuinely looking
at yourself i was generally looking at
this and expecting
donald j trump to have made in america
conditioner shampoos all that kind of
good stuff let me ask you is he still
operating this place does he still yeah
this place is this little his like
operated yes i don't think it's a good
look i think he needs to contact a cmo
that's running this and saying why are
we having stuff that we're producing
that's made in china i don't think it's
a good look to be honest with you i
agree yeah and i i i'm actually like
this is obviously some little bit of
like a little joke whatever whatever but
i would want and expect someone like
donald trump to only have made in
america property uh made america
material sure it's not made in chinatown
let me let me just see
san francisco it's what it is made in
chinatown anyway but uh you do travel a
lot
and i want you to look good you do spend
72 dollars on a haircut so i want you to
have the best of the best of the best
only the best
products for you are so amazing you're
always looking out for me i i genuinely
was hey final thoughts about brady final
thoughts about brady okay brady retired
okay were you surprised when he retired
no not really yeah but
you know to me i think um i think it's
good that he did when he did i i hate to
see when guys
even switching teams i mean obviously he
won another one but
you know when they just kind of fade off
because they suck i think that's a
shitty way to go for a guy like that
same with you know joe montana or favre
or whatever it's like
when you see guys who are that good for
that long and he's i think the epitome
of that
i think it's better that he left when he
was kind of still on top yeah
charlemagne the god called him the
greatest athlete of all time
charlemagne the guy calling the great
like meaning better than michael yeah i
wouldn't call him the greatest athlete
of all time he's definitely the greatest
i would say he's the most successful
footballer the greatest football player
of all time but here's what makes me a
little upset here
imagine if michael jordan retired which
he did briefly but then and then he did
it again and he came back from the you
know came back to the washington wizard
let's just say he won a championship
with the wizards let's just say michael
jordan after everything he did with the
bulls and then he retired and all he did
was thank the wizards and the great
organization they had he was there for
two years he was there to the other team
patriots for 20 years and all he did was
thank the wizards you'd be saying dude
what are you talking about you were a
chicago bull through and through
legend and that's the way i i look at
tom brady dude
congratulations you you you
you're the man you you took
tampa bay that was nothing franchise for
decades and then you took him super
awesome but let's not forget
you're a patriot so obviously he's a
little salty from his exit whether
that's bob kraft whether that's a
belichick thing he's a little salty
about that but i i do think that bill
belichick had a very classy tweet or a
memo that i cut out about brady i have a
problem on this here's what my
perspective is so let me ask you a
question so imagine you're brady okay
and
you are making your mind whether you're
gonna retire or not you talk to your
wife you talk to your kids and you say
you know what
i wake up in the morning i'm retiring
okay tell me the first five phone calls
you make before you're going to go
public
give me the first five phone calls you
make other than your family no no you're
not even even family you can't tell
everybody it's wife and i mean it's
immediate give me the five phone calls i
know where you're going with this it
needs to be the organization you're
retiring from first okay so perfect so
can we say
he probably is going to talk to bruce
charions
yeah
and and then after the coach
malcolm gladwell isn't that the owner
not malcolm gladwell
he doesn't have that kind of money but
the gladwell family i believe they own
this so
so you got so you got the customer
you've got the coach who else is going
to call
do you think he's going to call anybody
from the patriots organization
no no he's not going to alert them at
all you so you don't think he calls
anybody you don't think he has a good
relationship with krause where he calls
him and say hey jerry listen i was with
you for now jerry cross you're talking
about i'm not jerry cross i'm talking
about uh uh
robert
you're call robert kraft and say hey
you know here's where i'm at you don't
think he's going to make a phone call
like that
he's definitely not going to call that
relationship we know he's not going to
call bill he's not going to call well
isn't it
um
bob kraft that decided not to resign him
two years ago in 2019 i don't know who
it was but is that belichick is he i
think he called a few people okay and
i'm thinking one of the people he called
is from new england patriots
somebody leaked the information to the
news everybody he called and he says
tell me you didn't say it he believed
four people the one person that did say
it he was so annoyed that he says i'm
gonna snub you for my recognition screw
you guys i think people like that are so
sensitive to respecting them sharing
private information with you that if you
cross it they cross you i think it was
that simple i don't think it was i don't
disagree with you yeah i don't know
something happened whether it was
because
the fact that people leaked it he wanted
to be the one it wasn't official for
like 72 hours but i guarantee you it was
official
i guarantee it was official for 96 hours
didn't he put something on social media
about it but and before uh his team knew
he said in the interview no he never did
that then he never did he he said in the
interview i'm going to talk about and
see what i'm going to be doing and i'll
get get back to you guys after he lost
but but put up belichick still is
belichick still here for me to read or
is it up there uh
he did in his in his instagram post he
think the the obviously tampa bay
everything we just said he had one
reference to the patriots did you see it
he had one reference of the patriots
what was that he had a picture of him no
he's beating the patriots yeah beating
the patriots as a tampa bay buck this
year so there was a subtle
so go hand right there
i want to read here's what belichick
said i am can you make it a little
bigger so i can see it i am privileged
to have drafted i am privileged to have
drafted that's a statement meaning i
picked you
i am privileged to have drafted
and coached tom brady the ultimate
competitor and winner
tom's humble beginning in professional
football ultimately ended with him
becoming the best player in nfl history
tom consistently performed at the
highest level against competition that
always made him to number one player to
stop
his pursuit of excellence was
inspirational tom was professional on
and off the field and carried himself
with some cl with class integrity and
kindness
i thank tom what a powerful word i thank
tom
for his relentless pursuit of excellence
and positive impact on me
that's a pretty humble statement right
there i thank tom
for his relentless pursuit of excellence
and positive impact on me and the new
england patriots for 20 years good for
you how do you process that though
because you sounded a little sarcastic
about about which one about belichick no
no when i said i drafted meaning
don't forget i
risked everything on you because i
believed in you 199. 198 people did not
i picked you
i believed in you never forget that one
you were nobody and i chose
when when drew bledsoe when you got a
hit
and your knee was gone and you were
dropped and we benched you second half
drew bledsoe came and won that game and
took us to the super bowl and i had two
weeks to decide and everybody from
willie mcginnis everybody said
belichick's going to choose drew bledsoe
as a starting quarterback after having
signed a 100 million contract
i made the announcement publicly and i
said tom brady will start the super bowl
and bledsoe in an interview was
devastated
and he says every every player
quarterback looks for this position to
be in to go into the super bowl
but uh it is what it is and you can see
the interview with bless how tough it
was for him
belichick chose
brady now imagine if he doesn't
you just can't you know there's
you can't you have to know that there is
there is some value there man that's
that's the only thing i'm saying
belichick is trying to say listen i took
a chance on you okay
and listen without your drive there's no
way we went six
but still somebody had to pick you even
though nobody believed in you at that
time and i picked you as a starter
i i think it's a beautiful thing listen
to me i think brady when people talk
about brady versus jordan
greatest athlete it makes no sense i
mean the guy's got a vertical leap of a
six-year-old he's not going to be able
to jump that high okay he runs the zero
to 40 yards
right now not a good luck but it's not
an athlete but i'm going to tell you
something here when they took the heart
the of of
the one horse that nazi biscuit no it's
a one of the recent ones
they took the heart and they saw he was
in the 99.6 percentile right the horse
he wasn't the biggest
p the name is with a p horse just go to
the top of
uh kentucky there will be winners
secretariat not secretary no it's
another one what's the horse's name kai
the go to
go to a horse-winning
uh uh uh
not secretary go to horse winning
kentucky derby
uh winning kentucky derby at the names
i'll i'll tell you exactly what it is uh
somebody probably putting it down here
right now what the name is but anyways
when they talked about this horse
um
they said the guy had a heart
a massive heart that was going to win
just go to all of them buddy i don't
know why you're yeah just go to all of
them we'll figure out what the name is
in a minute here anyways the point is
this guy's got a heart of a champion
american pharaoh is who it is american
pharaoh uh he was not the biggest
he was not the fan he was he was not the
fastest not the strongest not the
biggest he didn't look impressive
but when they measured his heart you
know they bought him for like five
thousand dollars you know that horse was
bound for like five thousand dollars or
fifteen thousand dollars you know his
stud fee alone is three hundred thousand
dollars per stud fee
okay so
you know that was on brady but somebody
believed in him
and uh credit goes to both of them and
the the league will miss him although i
think the nfl is right now stacked
with a lot of great
talent that's going to take this league
for sure make it exciting for another
day i just hope that he does not
go away meaning i hope he does what you
know peyton manning has done
has done and even drew brees and the
legends and just still be a part of the
game but he'll do it his way he'll do
that as he should he's not going to do
it like the other guys to me i don't see
him playing as big a role as those guys
just his personality isn't really that
that type of commentator you know
analyst like he's just not that that
dude you know but
i agree i hope he does i just
is there a bigger stud
in
in the world oh what i was gonna tell
brady i was going to say i didn't make
my point i'd say he's the greatest
athlete of all time he's the greatest
winner of all time yeah he's the
greatest winner of all time listen when
you play against somebody else michael
jordan
you play finals you could have a bad day
the knicks could beat you first game
when he played against the knicks in the
playoffs that means he would have been
out of the playoffs if it's only one
game
but this guy you have one game and you
win seven at it was a seven seven out of
ten yeah that's insane you do that and
the the argument is always from the
giants fans eli beat them twice yeah did
you see what eli said eli said i just
want to sit there and say i think i'm
uniquely qualified
because
i watched you win when i was in college
in super bowl then i played against you
and i watched you win when i was in the
league then i watched you win a super
bowl after i retired and he used the
words he says you were gracious enough
to let me win two right
correct
yeah
no
his biggest foils were the manning guys
he had to go through peyton manning
every year bateman had to go through him
and the the two super bowls that he lost
other than philly was to eli manning and
people had to literally catch balls on
top of their helmet yeah in order to
beat tom brady you had me
you had me at catch balls yeah well
listen uh
do you want to make it public that you
are subscribed to his only fans because
he did say yeah mike everyone by the way
mike gritlin has the only fans tim and
dogs both uh not at the same time
put up this website mike ritland's book
if you want to tell everybody the book
adam uh uh
again uh on
how to un [ __ ] america is that what it
is it is how to unfuck america yeah it's
an illustrated manual can you open up
the picture of it
open-minded amazon and put the link
below for people to be able to go buy it
if there's if there's anything we could
say about the legendary mike clinton
over here is that we always have a
respectful open-minded conversation and
we are doing our part to unfuck america
three times on the podcast man mike baby
thank you thank you mike take care buddy
yes bye bye bye bye by the way tomorrow
tomorrow what are we doing tomorrow
tomorrow we're doing jordan peterson
it's going to be in the house for a few
hours and i think it's going to be on
the other channel for three hours but
it's going to be on the other channel
instead of this channel or is it on pvp
podcast i still don't know which one it
is i think we're doing pog pvd podcast
and it's 12 o'clock it's at 12 o'clock
tomorrow
all right
it's 12 o'clock tomorrow on whatever the
time is on youtube that's what the time
will be we'll see you guys tomorrow if
you've got questions you want to ask joe
rogan send me a nacho rogan jordan
peterson send me a tweet maybe we'll
address it tomorrow take care everybody
bye bye bye
you